les premières traces depuis passe hummer
dans cette région-là
dames
deuxième cmcr herbe en zik et à l'époque
où les phéniciens qui étaient des
pêcheurs déjà des marins nous actons
donc automatiquement des pêcheurs
également sont venus installer sur les
bords du lac ici des pêcheries
et ce sont les plus anciennes traces de
pêche qui vient dans cette région là les
phéniciens
avait donné à ceux à cet endroit ce lac
le nom d'une de nos divinités
qui était joueuse de de lire d'où le nom
de kiné readynet ça veut dire la petite
lire mais c'était aussi le nom d'une
déesse de la plupart ont fini siens de
cette période
et les phéniciens donc sont restés
quelques temps dans cette région là ils
ont d'ailleurs organisé aussi tout le
nord du pays et jusqu'à l'arrivée des
hispaniques dans cette région
la région du clean air est est tombé par
le sol savez quand jésus a divisé le
pays entre les différentes tribus
comme le dit le livre du prophète isaïe
d'un chapitre 9 le peuple qui marche
dans les ténèbres voit une grande
lumière donc c'est la tribu de
naphtaline tribunal de naples où des
abus long qui se sont partagé cette
région là surtout la tribune estrie et
dans le talmud c'est à dire les
commentaires rabbinique sur le la bible
il nous est dit que jésus ait à donner
le monopole de la pêche à la tribu de
nefta n'initie sur le lac les autres
tribus avaient le droit de pêcher mais
uniquement à la ligne et pêcher ou filet
c'était quelque chose qui était
l'apanage de la seule tribu de des frais
à partir donc de ce moment là il ya eu
des pêcheries juive se sont installés
compris le relais des pêcheries
phénicienne mais dans le canal
descendant d'écriture et brave de la
bible il ya assez peu de mention de la
pêche il ya un seul endroit où tout et
pour tout mais les questions de filet
c'est un livre du prophète habacuc mais
nous est dit que les babyloniens et
chaldéens convenir vers israël
sacrifie à l'infini comme si c'était un
dieu
par conséquent il n'y a pas eu un grand
développement de la pêche à cette
période là il faut attendre la période
du deuxième temps c'est à dire la
période du nouveau testament pour qu' il
y ait un développement important de la
pêche dans cette région nous sommes
issus en face de nous sur la rive
occidentale
il y a
de nombreuses pêcheries qui ce qu'ils
ont été installés à l'épreuve du
deuxième temps c'est à dire à l'époque
romaine en particulier
de la région où est issu du lac la
partie ouest du lac était
essentiellement une population juive
l'autre côté c'est à dire sur le à l'est
on avait une liste de dix villes
rappelle nadine la décapole des cas
police grecque savait elle est divine
étaient des villes autonomes des villes
grecques autonome donc non juive ce qui
nous explique que de l'autre côté du lac
ont élevé des ports tandis qu'ici on est
évidemment dans une région qui n'était
pas peuplé par des païens dont je
n'avais pas de porc et la région de
niagara l'ajout de guerre à sac notre
artiste différent sous ses airs
angéliques se trouve de l'autre côté du
lac
il est à noter que le nombre des
pêcheries du côté grec du lac était
nettement moins développé que du côté
ouest que du côté juif et on trouve
pratiquement tous les kilomètres de sept
heures de cette région on trouve des
traces d'un port de pêche un port de
pêche très développé et la pêche était
très développé disons que il y avait là
des entreprises de pêche qui était
entreprise familiale avec des porcs
étaient très très nombreux et puis
procurer une des ressources importants
du pays il y avait non seulement des
pêcheries mais il y avait aussi des
industries de conservation du poisson de
salaisons du poisson mais par exemple la
ville de magdala art est un grand centre
de la salaison du poisson pas trouvé
grâce à la sardine
la sardine du lac étaient considérés
comme des petites façon qu'avait dans le
lard nouveau testament fait une
différence entre les grands et les
petits poissons par exemple dans le
récit de la deuxième pêche miraculeuse
dans l'évangile de jean il est question
de la pêche miraculeuse qui avait eu
lieu deux cent cinquante trois grands
poissons
à côté de ces grands poissons
ce n'est l'histoire du jeune garçon qui
avait cinq pains et de poissons qui ont
servi à jésus pour multiplier ses pas et
ses poissons et nourrir une foule de
5000 personnes
bien il est question qu'il avait à sa
disposition
cinq pains et deux petits pois sa
petite voix sont venues tout à l'heure
c'est essentiellement la satim
la sardine c'est le poisson le plus
courant qu'on peut trouver sur le lac
vous pouvez trouver à cette époque là
c'est un fait ordinaire pour
la nourriture des habitants du lac lac
la sardine était aussi commercialiser et
exporter qu'on a vu à partir de centres
comme celui de magdala dégoûté de
s'aggraver les grands poissons
alors vidal
trois grands types de poissons
essentiellement de grands poissons
le premier c'est ce qu'on appelle
improprement le saint pierre de saint
pierre est ainsi nommé parce que nous
avons dans l'évangile un épisode où
jésus payent l'impôt donc avec un
poignard à une pièce de monnaie qu'elle
était trouvée dans la gueule d'un
poisson il ordonne à pierre d'aller au
lac de tirer à la ligne le premier
poisson qui vit à l'écrit tombera sous
la main de lui ouvrir la bouche pedra do
celle qu'on va devoir payer l'impôt est
pourvue et dont jésus
et aujourd'hui on déguste sur les bords
du lac rêvons appelle le saint pierre le
saint-clair son nom véritable c'est le
tilapia
si la pièce est un poisson tropical
parce qu'ici on arrive un climat quasi
tropicale
et surtout très très connu par les
africains d accueil les africains
connaissent très bien sur quoi ça la
seule chose qu'on peut dire c'est que ce
poisson là n'est pas le saint pierre
pour une bonne et simple raison que nous
ne prendrai jamais tilapia à l'hameçon
ne mangera jamais à l'hameçon parce que
la femelle
utilise sa gueule pour garder ses yeux
quand jusqu'à ce que ces technologies
les petits restent dans la la bouche de
la maman n'est pas conséquent jamais
ainsi la pierre de mordre à l'hameçon ce
bois sont donc est considéré comme le
vin déplaçant les plus fins et les plus
savoureux qu'il ya ici dans le lac mais
le poisson saint pierre mondy cette
façon dans lequel il avait apprise de
rooney raisonnablement une des
différentes sortes on écarte cette
mesure via plusieurs variétés de cas qui
elles aussi sont considérés comme des
grands pinceaux et puis il ya un autre
grand poisson que l'on trouve dans cette
région là c'est le poisson chat
et un poisson chat il est extrêmement
savoureux aussi mais il n'est pas
consommée par les juifs parce que c'est
un poisson non casher c'est un poisson
effet qu'il n'a pas des cayes elle
savait que selon les lois de bioéthique
il est interdit de consommer 1 comme un
juif des poissons sans est calme ça vous
explique la parabole du fils et qu'il
retrouve dans le chapitre xiii de
l'évangile de matthieu en fait dans les
évangiles sont nommés quatre types
différents de filet à 4 mots grecs
différents pour désigner quatre types de
filets mais la plupart des traducteurs
qui n'était pas du tout et pêcheurs il
ne connaissait rien à la pêche sous par
gerald casser la tête ces quatre moulins
et les autres à nous de simplement par
des filets c'est bien qu'on n'est pas
plus avancé avez vous parlé rapidement
de ces quatre types de finir premier de
ses filets
c'est celui dont il est question dans ce
chapitre xiii de l'évangile de marc
j'ai dit que le royaume des cieux est
semblable filet et que des prêcheurs ou
jetés dans la mer on ramène le filet sur
le rivage mais on fait le tri des postes
alors ce poids sur ce filet c'est ce
qu'on appelle la scène c'est un fait
mais le faire entre 150 et 200 mètres de
long et rectangulaire
et il est d'une part dans la partie
supérieure il y à des flotteurs
et la partie inférieure de la délaisse
de telle façon que quand il est mouillé
dans la mer il fasse une murale
verticale
aujourd'hui on utilisait encore bien peu
plus encore ce fils et en afrique en
particulier
mais on utilisait des restes du plomb
à l'époque de nouveau testament on
n'utilisait pas déleste de plomb c'est
mon ami le regretté main dennoun étaient
50 ans pêcheur dans le lac est découvert
l'énigme
l'a découvert sur tous les bords du lac
que vous avez peut-être pouvoir en
trouver sur celle de la chance des
pierres
percées qui servait de l'est
[Musique]
la plupart des foules même ignoré ce
phénomène là dans la mesure où on
pensait que si les trous qu'il y avait
dans le dans les longères
lac ramène sur la belge notamment après
le temps de tempête
était de tout naturel
bon ok par l'érosion en réalité manette
vous l'a prouvé que ce n'était rien que
c'était d'être ou artificiels
on va très bien l'endroit où ils ont été
percés nous va très bien l'usure de la
corde pour fonder ses pierres dont
certains étaient des silex vous savez
que le silex c'est une pièce extrêmement
dure
et on s'en servait quand on avait percé
un trou on s'en servait pour lester les
filets le filet était replié en
accordéon et il était manoeuvré par deux
équipes mais l'équipe qui restait sur la
terre ferme et claire moyen d'une pêche
tenez une fusée verticale et puis une
deuxième et clips ou qu'ils étaient sur
le bateau sur lequel était repliée le
filet en accordéon vous faisait tout à
l'heure qui partait perpendiculairement
au visage et qui mouillait ne filait
derrière lui
lorsque le fils était totalement
déployés dont perpendiculairement à la
côte le bateau faisait 1 90 de guerre et
le tir et lefler derrière lui qui
ramassait donc que tout ce qu'il y avait
dans la mer et ensuite ils arrivaient
150 mètres plus loin où 200 mètres plus
loin sur le visage ont tiré le filet sur
le rivage on faisait le tri des poissons
on faisait le tri notamment entre les
poissons cacher et puis les poissons
chats qui était non casher et qui
étaient rejetés à la mer
et ça vous explique justement que cette
image que jésus font que le royaume de
dieu et comme ce filet qui a été jeté
dans la mer qui ramasse toutes sortes de
poissons s'avère la parole de dieu
s'adresse à tous les hommes
si c'est un temps de grâce et un ton
dieu suspend ses jugements
mais il y aura une deuxième temps où le
filet sera ramenée sur le sens de ce
sera le jugement et ralliera le tri
entre les justes et les injustes ceux
qui ont reçu la parole de dieu et ceux
qui ne leur ont pas reçu
deuxième type de finale c'est ce qu'on
appelle les pertes des
éperviers c'est un filet en forme de
cloche
il est aussi resté dans sa partie
inférieure
et c'est un filet qui est d'utiliser
l'eau loin de la côte les et manoeuvré
par par un seul homme il ya un geste
très spécial fou que quand on jette le
feeling se déploie et il en cage en
quelque sorte une partie de la mer
le poisson n'a pas le temps de partir et
se trouve prisonnier à l'intérieur de
cette cloche et l'on plonge
pour attacher ensuite le bas du filet on
ramène l'ensemble et puis on l'a aussi
on fait le tri du poisson dans les mêmes
conditions que celles que nous avons
évoqué tout à l'heure remarquons que
c'était ce genre de fille dès que kiev
manoeuvrer continuité d'un deuxième
multiplication des pains car il nous est
dit que continuer on lui a dit que
c'était jésus qui était là il prit son
vêtement c'est à dire une espèce de
slips parce qu'il était nu il était nu
parce qu'il plongeait pour attacher les
pv au bas de combat deux du fine et
3e fine et c'est ce qu'on appelle le
filet véranda il a deux formes il a 2 2
deux variétés de ce filet très
exactement
on appelle le sud est où le filet
véranda ou le très mal très mal ainsi
nommée parce que c'est un filet à 3
miles comme son nom l'indiqué en fait ce
sont trois fils et qui sont accolés les
uns aux autres avec des mailles de
différents calibres ce filet il est
embarqué sur un bateau qui mouille en
cercle comme ça en cercle fermé ça veut
dire qu'il engage une partie de la mer
et les bacs reste à l'intérieur du
cercle et quand le filet a complètement
été mauvais on fait le maximum de bruit
on tape on crie ça pouvait faire une
effrayer le poisson le poisson pas dans
toutes les directions et forcément
qu'est-ce qu'il va rencontrer le filet
c'est un obstacle il arrive arrive dans
la première mailles du filet il s'affole
ni ce débat plus il est bas plus il sent
période l'ific dans le deuxième filet
s'il parvient par s'effacer deuxième
filet il trouve un troisième filet donc
il a eu pratiquement aucune chance
d'échapper au bout de quelques temps on
relève le filet on récupère les poissons
ainsi 1,6 ainsi réaliser maintenant le
poisson il a une autre possibilité c'est
qui peut sauter par dessus les
alors on en paie un quatrième type de
finale qui le fuit les vérandas c'est un
tréma y avait encore un peu plus
sophistiqué dans lequel sur lequel mon
ami à d'autres filets en forme de toi si
vous voulez pour empêcher nos passions
de sauter par dessus donc si vous voulez
voilà essentiellement les quatre types
de filles qui étaient employés par les
pêcheries du lac
maintenant il y avait également on verra
tout à l'heure quand on sera ta femme
sage de réserve tout à l'heure que vous
rencontrez pas ce qu'il en est en face
de vous ici regardez
vous avez cet éperon rocheux là on est
arrivé par ailleurs talent
c'est ce qu'on appelle les cordes de
britten
ça il ya eu là
une célèbre bataille entre les croisés
et saladin
dans cette région là
les croisés ont subi formidable défaite
qui leur a fait perdre le royaume de
jérusalem
ça a été la fin de la première croisade
les croisés avaient rassemblé toutes
leurs cavaliers pratiquement toutes
leurs armes et ou du chevalier de
terre-sainte s'étaient rassemblés à
accous saint jean d'âcre pour récupérer
ici la femme de raymonde toulouse qui
avait été emprisonné par saladin
tibériade
et
saladin avait tendu un piège aux ont
croisé danser dans ce défilé c'est de se
défiler des cordes footing
quand les gelées c'était amplement à
jouer les chevaliers avait tout à fait
une chevauchée extrêmement rassemble les
il avait perdu toutes les réserves d'eau
avait été
transpercée par les flèches des archers
arabes qui les harcelaient il n'avait
qu'un seul but c'était d'arriver au lac
pour moi et quand ils sont arrivés dans
ce défilé ils ont vu le lac pour eux
c'était absolument magnifique mais ils
ont constaté que les arabes la barrer la
route
barrée complètement là toute la largeur
du défilé qu'à cela ne tienne on emploie
la tactique d'obélix on fonce dans le
tas on écrase tout et on s'en va
c'était la technique de la chasse des
chevaliers cuirassé croisés mais en
général cette charge là elle est
irrésistible non plus de ça il y avait
de la pente que vous voyez donc avait
tout pour pouvoir réussir et la charge
est parti à toute vitesse et quand il
est arrivé au niveau des lignes ennemies
sanader fait ouvrir les rangs et la
charge croisé est passé dans le vide et
quand
l'accent 3 a été passé salade à fait
refermée les rangs
et l'écran les chevaliers étaient coupés
de leurs gendarmes ça veut dire de la
fonderie que tu es resté de l'autre côté
tout pendant toute la journée ils ont
essayé de charger un contrepoids
vous imaginez ce que ça veut dire
charger à contretemps ça a été l'échec
et le soir alors un cheval qui était
tombé à terre c'est un chevalier fischer
n'émet pas se relever et tous les
chevaliers terre sainte était as fait
tes morts c'est bien qu'à vous de jeu à
l'aide a été ouverte avant cela d'un
sans le moindre combat c'est là aussi
qu'il ya eu un épisode de la tempête
apaisée et de jésus marchant sur les
eaux avait une action sur la mer
c'est
c'est quelque chose évidemment puis nous
sommes tout à fait incroyable d'imaginer
qu'il puisse avoir des tempêtes
dangereux sur ce lac
mais effectivement en hiver particulier
il peut s'avérer il peut s'élever des
tempêtes extrêmement brutale est
extrêmement violent j'ai vu une fois des
vagues qui déferlaient sur la promenade
de tibériade que telle manière que même
les et cafés les bistrots qui avait
notre terrasse la bande et des ménages
est la leur
star les deux chaînes elle est rentrée à
l'intérieur tellement la villa
violence du courant était forte ce matin
ce même jour le soir jésus leur dit
passons de notre bord
après avoir envoyé la foule ils l'ont
menée dans la barque où il se trouvait
il y avait aussi d'autres bacs avec lui
et ce devant un grand tourbillon mais
les fous se jeter dans la bas pour point
qu'elle se remplisse et déjà on verra ça
tout à l'heure pour que ça sur le bateau
là et lui donnait à la poupe sur le plus
à le réveiller a dit m ne t'inquiète pas
de ce que l'opération s'étant avérée
menaçable devons aider et la mer et des
silences tétouan et le vent c'est ça
lutins grand calme puis je leur dis
pourquoi avez-vous ils peuvent comment
avez-vous points deux fois il faut
saisir une grande frayeur et se dire les
autres quel est donc celui ci a qui
obéissent même le vent et la mer
comme jésus se trouvait près du lac de
gêner arrête et que la foule se pressait
autour de lui pour entendre la parole de
dieu
il vit au bord du lac de bart doubs les
pêcheurs étaient descendus pour laver
leur filet il monta dans l'une de ces
bacs étaient assis vent et le pria de
s'éloigner un peu de la terre puis
s'assied et de la batterie d'enseigner
la foule parce qu'il eut cessé de parler
dit à simon avant son plein et jetez vos
filets pour pêcher simon répondu m sam
ont travaillé toute la nuit sans rien
prend mais sur ta parole je jetterai le
fils est né en je t ai pris une grande
quantité de poissons et leurs filets
seront p il fait signe à leurs
compagnons qui étaient dans une autre
base de venir les aider il vint et
remplir les deux vagues au point qu'elle
s'enfonçait quand il veut cela pierre
tombale ou genou de jésus et du seigneur
retire toi de moi parce que je suis un
empêcheur l épouvante la bulle avait
saisi ainsi que tous ceux qui étaient à
lui vécu à cause de la pêche qu'ils
avaient fait en était de même de jacques
de jean fils de zébédée associé de simon
alors j'ai juste à simon ne craint pas
des hommes et tu seras pêcheurs d'hommes
et ont ramené les barques sur la terre
ils laissèrent tout est jeu suivez
beaucoup de choses se sont passées sur
ce lac
et nous sommes vraiment dans le centre
au coeur même de les manger
alors ici nous nous trouvons devant ce
qui serait le golgotha
et est ce qui a donné à gordon l'idée
que ça pouvait être le golgotha c'est
aussi le fait que cette falaise que vous
voyez là à grosso modo la forme d'un
crâne vous pouvez distingué avec un peu
d'imagination des deux yeux le nez on
voyait la bouche manière beaucoup plus
claire il ya quelques années de cela
mais il ya eu des éboulements de terrain
ces derniers temps et la bouche a
disparu d'autre part la gare d autobus a
été réhaussée et a donc à cacher une
partie du golgotha ça c'était délibéré
s'était voulue pour que précisément le
lieu soit d'y figurer alors celui sur le
plan géologique est ici une faille dans
un éperon rocheux qui commence un peu
plus au nord est qu'ils se dirigent vers
le sud qui traversait la route et se
prolonger jusque sur nos monts du temps
ce qui voudrait dire que nous sommes ici
dans une partie du mont moriah
l'endroit pour abraham a sacrifié zac
exactement et il ya eu d'autres ici une
une coupure qui a été fait a
difficilement dans cet éperon rocheux
pour pouvoir faire passer la route ici
qui va d'ouest en est en direction donc
de du jourdain on sait d'autre part que
cet endroit était un lieu d'exécution et
on est situé si l'endroit à l'endroit où
vraisemblablement
etienne a été supplicié parce qu'on
trouve ici à quelque distance de là à
une église qui dit fier qu'est dédié à
saint-etienne donc les neuf
ressemblement non loin de l'endroit où a
lieu son martyre la technique
d'exécution des condamnés c'était de les
précipiter du haut de la falaise et de
les achever à coups de pierres si on
arrive en bas il n'était pas mort
où jésus at il été crucifié alors là
c'est quelque chose aussi qui est
inhabituel dans notre mentalité parce
que nous sommes habitués à de véritables
images d'epinal à ce niveau là on voit
les trois croix qui se lève au sommet de
la colline or la crucifixion celui-ci
ait lieu en bas là où sont les autobus
pour fois pour que les passants puissent
assister à l'exécution et puis c'était
un avertissement voilà ce qui vous
attend si vous déroger au pouvoir romain
les croix n'était pas du tout autre
comme on leur présente et
on a l'habitude de représenter des fois
qu'ils font plusieurs mètres de haut
mais les trois étaient pratiquement à
hauteur d'homme
d'autre part la croix ce n'était pas du
tout la croix latines telle qu on la
représente la croix elle avait la forme
d'un thé et le poteau verticale rester
en place entre les deux exécutions est
ce que le bull la croix que le condamné
porter n'était pas là croate elle qui la
représente dans les scènes où jésus
porte la croix on ne portait que la
poutre transversale qu'on appelait le
patibulaire d'où l'expression avoir une
mine patibulaire et la manière du
crucifié n'était pas du tout celle qu'on
vous présente aussi on a retrouvé en
1904 78,6
d'enfants faisant drew sur le mont des
oliviers
le squelette d'un crucifié dans un
ossuaire qui portait le nom du défunt
portait le nom de yoann yoyo annan
bennes agricoles et quand on a ouvert
l'ossuaire on a découvert les os d'un
homme d'une trentaine 32 30 à 35 ans à
peu près et les eaux d'un enfant de
quatre ans donc le pain uran et le fils
qui s'appelait urana aussi qu étaient
enterrés et c'était ben d'agde accueille
sa venue uran et son fischer annan le
fils du pendu
la crucifixion était comparée à une
pendaison
et et on sait que les romains avaient
l'habitude qu'ont pendant que les
condamnés étaient en train d'agoniser
sur la croix de massacrer nos familles
devant leurs yeux
donc ce jeune garçon de 4 ans a dû être
mis à mort en même temps que son père
qui était en train d'agoniser sur la
croix
maintenant ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on a découvert les la première fois
la trace d'une fausse fiction est
intéressant de noter que le clou en
question n'étaient pas enfoncé comme on
le représente dans les scènes de la
passion dans les deux chez superposés
nationaux tu es dans les talons les deux
talons du crucifié été transpercée par
un énorme clou d'une dette de 12 à 15 cm
de long environ ce qui veut dire que la
position du crucifié sur la croix était
celle là
et quand aucune clé tu es dans les été
enfoncés ici dans les avant bras on a
retrouvé les traces du cloud sur les os
de l'avant-bras du crucifié donc on sait
exactement aujourd'hui commente été
pratiqué une crucifixion
il y avait une autre manière du crucifié
c'était de placer les deux les deux
criées du crucifié de chaque côté du
poteau verticale et de mettre un clou
dans chaque pied dans chaque salon bon
comment jésus a été crucifié on ne sait
pas exactement mais en tout cas dans une
de ces deux méthodes lave sur son jeu
vous imaginez la position vraiment
inconfortable qu'on pouvait avoir sur la
croix pour prolonger l'agonie on mettait
un ami à mi-pente disons d'avoir la
moitié de la croix espèce de siège sur
lequel le crucifié pouvait prendre appui
aussi pour pouvoir respirer un peu plus
à l'aise ce qui faisait que l'agonie
pouvait durer les heures et des heures
voire des jours et des jours plusieurs
jours en tout cas bon c'est que jésus
n'est pas mort comme ça il a été il est
mort quand il a résolu de le faire
sortie de la ville pour aller vers
l'endroit appelé le crâne ce qui se dit
en hébreu golgotha c'est là qu'ils le
crucifièrent et avec lui deux autres un
de chaque côté jésus au milieu
pilâtre est déjà aussi un écriteau qui
plaça sur la croix il était écrit juste
de nazareth le roi des juifs
beaucoup de juifs lure cette inscription
parce que l'endroit où jésus fut
crucifié étaient près de la ville
étaient écrites en hébreu et en grec et
en latin les chefs des prêts des juifs
d'hier tapis là tu n'écris pas le roi
des juifs mais plutôt cet homme a dit je
suis le roi des juifs il a répondu ce
que j'ai écrit je les écris à présent va
crucifier jésus les soldats prirent ses
vêtements il enfile 4 pas une pour
chaque soldat
mettrait aussi sa tunique était sans
couture d'une seule pièce depuis l'eau
jusqu'en bas et se dire entre eux ne la
déchire on pas mais tire au sort pour
savoir à qui elle sera c'est ainsi que
sa complice est paroles de l'écriture et
se sont partagé mes vêtements ils ont
tiré au sort mme amon abus voilà ce que
firent les soldats près de la croix de
jésus se tenait sa mère la soeur de sa
mère marie la femme le clos passe et
marie de magdala jésus vit sa mère est
prêt dès le disciple qu'il aimait dit à
sa mère femme voici ton fils j'ai dit
aux disciples voici ta mère et les ce
moment le disciple ne pourrai l'a pris
avec lui après cela jésus qui savait que
tout est accompli dit afin que
l'écriture soit se réalise pleinement
j'ai soif il avait là un vase plein de
vinaigre des soldats remplir une éponge
à fixer à une branche d europe hélas
trop cher de sa bouche jésus prit le
vinaigre il dit tout est accompli plus
il baissa la tête et randy l'esprit
c'était la préparation de la fête du
shabbat et ce shabbat était un grand
jour solennel craignant que les corps
nus reste sur la croix pendant le
shabbat justement dérape il est comprise
les gens ont crucifié parce que quand on
disait les jambes vous comprenez on
pouvait plus prendre appui sur les
jambes et la mort intervenez en quelques
minutes donc on a hâte et la mort et il
fallait que les tout soit terminé pour
le shabbat
soldats privés nous briser les gens du
premier puis du second des condamnés qui
avaient été crucifié jésus quand ils
s'approchèrent de jésus il fit qu elle
vu qu'il était déjà mort ne lui brisait
pas les jambes mais un des soldats lui
transperçait le côté avec une lance
aussitôt une sortie du sang et de l'eau
c'est lui qui a vu ces choses rend
témoignage son témoignage est vrai et
c'est qu'il dit la vérité afin que vous
croyez aussi en effet ceci est arrivé
afin que ce passage de l'écriture soit
accompli aucun de ces zones sera brisée
et ailleurs l'écriture dit encore ils
verront celui qu'ils ont transpercé
donc ici nous nous trouvons d'en voir un
endroit qui montre que nous étions ici
dans un lieu qui était un lieu exploiter
d'exploitation agricole important c'est
ce qui a convaincu gordon que nous
étions ici certainement dans un endroit
du golgotha ce qui nous est dit qu à
côté de l'endroit où jésus a été
crucifié il y avait un jardin et on a
retrouvé effectivement ici les traces
d'un jardin et notamment une citerne le
système pour emmagasiner l'eau et 7 6 1
et est énorme elle est là une capacité
de 2 de contenance absolument
extraordinaire et qui permet d'irriguer
une surface importante donc ici c'était
une propriété d'un homme riche et en
même temps c'était un endroit où il y
avait donc un jardin qui était exploité
notamment pour la vigne on a retrouvé un
petit peu plus loin un pressoir à vin et
par conséquent ici ça correspond
vraiment aux données ventilées vous
pouvez jeter un coup d'oeil dans la
citerne si vous voulez il ya de l'eau
d'ailleurs à l'heure actuelle ça vous
donne une petite idée là profondeur vous
donne une petite idée et tout ça voyez
vous si tout ce qui est recouvert de
tuiles rouges c'est la citerne vous
imaginez la capacité
alors vous apercevez c'est un pressoir à
vin qui était dans ce jardin dont il est
question ce qui prouve bien qu'on était
dans un jardin
regardez comment se présenter un
pressoir à vin et on met telegraph coupé
lahoud endroit qui est pavé on mettait
une barrière du pin qui servait de
filtre et on mettait un portique en bois
ou sur lesquels étaient suspendus des
cordes et le vin élevé zain était foulé
aux pieds parce que on doit écraser le
raisin juste suffisamment pour que le
juge soit exprimé mais il ne faut pas
broyer les pépins de raisin car sur une
voie les pépins de raisin ça va donner
un goût amer aux vins
alors on se suspendait à des corps a ses
codes plus pendait sur le portique pour
ne pas glisser et c'était un travail
très pénible donc on changeait les
équipes de tân son nhât assez
fréquemment et pendant qu'une équipe
était en train de fouler le gras il y
avait les autres qui chantait pour lui
de redonner du courage et il chante et
les psaumes qu'on appelle les psaumes à
chanter sur la grille titre vous avez
des psaumes qui porte ce titre à santé
sur la grille titre dit il ça vient du
mot gâteau hébreu qui signifie le
pressoir donc c'était lectures et chants
que l'on chantait pour remercier dieu
d'abord et deuxièmement pour encourager
les
c'est des fous la foulée halle aux
grains
alors ici nous sommes dans une
structure qui est un tombeau du 1er
siècle donc il ya de l'époque de jésus
vous êtes rentré dedans et vous vous
êtes vous avez pu vous rendre compte de
la somme de travail que représente à
l'époque où on n'a pas les moyens dont
on dispose aujourd'hui pour un creuset
un tombeau de cesse de ce type là donc
il faut vraiment être riche pour pouvoir
se payer un tombeau de ceux de cette
catégorie là vous êtes entré ici dans la
première chambre qui est la chambre des
plats et ce tombeau il a quelque chose
de très spécial qui n'est pas courant
dans les tombeaux de l'époque il a eu sa
chambre funéraire est logiquement qu'il
ya une seule chambre funéraire elle est
dans le prolongement de la chambre des
pleurs et non pas sur le côté comme ici
bon il faut vous en présenter qu'à
l'époque la porte elle était beaucoup
moins grande que ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui elle était à peu près moitié
moins grande donc il fallait se baisser
pour pouvoir entrer et c'est ce qui nous
est raconté que les apôtres ont dû se
baisser pour pouvoir voir ce qu'il y
avait à l'intérieur
vous avez vu à l'intérieur les trois
reposoir qu'il y avait de chaque côté de
la chambre funéraire quand quelqu'un
décéder on l'enveloppé dans des
bandelettes avec le désert aux maths et
on le déposer sur un tir reposoir
et il restera environ un ordre et un an
après on récupérer les eaux la chair
était décomposée ont récupéré les autres
on les mettait dans des petites boîtes
en terre cuite ou en pierre qui ont
placé dans des niches qui était situé
dans une autre partie de la pièce
federer c'était ce qu'on appelait être
rassemblés à ces instances être décédé
et la tombe était prête pour d'autres
sépultures quand ensuite la famille
c'était une propriété familiale d'une
tombe dont étaient rassemblés dans le
tombeau de ses pairs
on creuse et d'autres chambres
funéraires et vous pouvez avoir des
tombeaux
kvx chambre funéraire qui était selon
l'importance de la famille ou sait
l'importance de ce qui était enterré
dans cet endroit là donc
jésus a été enterré de cette manière là
et que logiquement n'est condamné les
condamnés à mort n'étaient pas enterrés
dans des tombes ils étaient jetés à la
fosse commune et dieu n'a pas permis que
son fils soit je tiens la fosse commune
parce qu'ils devaient ressuscité donc
automatiquement il a permis que c'est un
brusque et et joseph d'areva t était un
disciple de jésus l'accueil dans sa
propre tombe vous inquiète jamais
personne n'avait été mis
maintenant on peut se représenter ce qui
s'est produit le jour de la deûle à
lille tenant ce vivement et de la
résurrection valurent le texte
après cela joseph d'arimathie qu'est
disciples de jésus mais en secret par
crainte d'effrayer ficelles juifs
demandent à pilate la permission
d'enlever le corps de jésus pilates lui
permis il va donc y enlevant le corps de
jésus nicodème l'homme qui auparavant
étaient allés trouver jésus de nuit 20
aussi il a porté un mélange d'environ 30
kg de mire et d'aloès il prit donc le
corps de jésus l'enveloppé dans des
bandelettes avec les aromates comme
c'est la coutume dans ce livre chez les
juifs
or il y avait un jardin à l'endroit où
jésus avait été crucifié et dans ce
jour-là un tombeau neuf où personne
n'avait encore jamais été mis ce fut là
qu'ils déposaient jésus parce que
c'était la préparation de la pac des
juifs et que le tombeau était proche et
de fait il était proche de l'endroit où
on était tout à l'heure le premier jour
de la semaine marie de magdala ce rendu
au tombeau de bon matin alors qu'il
faisait encore sombre elle vu que la
pierre avait été enlevée alors la pierre
elle et elle roulait dans cette encore
ce que vous voyez là
mais la tombe disons la pièce de ce
tombeau là elle avait disparu on n'a
jamais retrouvé alors on en avait ramené
une autre que vous voyez là
qui est qui ressemble à celle qui était
voulait et même si elle était moins
grande que ce que l'on imagine
maintenant c'était quand même pour des
femmes quelque chose de très dur de
pouvoir l'a roulé elle courut trouver
simon-pierre et l'autre dissipe que
jésus et mais lundi ils ont enlevé le
seigneur du tombeau ne savons pas où ils
ont mis père et l'autre du sud sortir
donc est allé au tombeau il pouvait tout
des ensembles mais l'autre dissipe couru
plus vite que pierre et rival le premier
tombeau il se pencha avril où il fallait
se pencher pour pouvoir entrer et vie
les bandelettes posé à terre cependant
une autre a pas à
simon lui qui le suivait arriva il
entrait dans le tombeau il vit les
bandelettes
poser en fait s'est affaissé à terre le
texte de terme grec signifie affaissé à
terre le linge qu'on avait mis sur jésus
sur la tête de jésus n'était pas avec
les bandes mais entourée d'un enroulé
dans un endroit pas alors l'autre du sud
qui était arrivé le premier au tombeau
entre a aussi il vit et il crut à qu'est
ce qui l'a amené à voir et à croire qu
est ce qu il a vu qu'il a amené à croire
les les bonnes et les bandelettes
affaissé ça veut dire que quand jésus
est ressuscité
eh bien il n'a pas déroulé les
bandelettes il est passé au travers
vous savez qu'il y là il était passé au
travers de des murs qui étaient fermés
dans la chambre haute bien de la même
manière il est passé dans sa
résurrection au travers des bandelettes
et par conséquent tout cette espèce de
mme oumy qui étaient créés par ces sept
ans bonnement s'est affaissé sur place
et c'est ce que les deux disciples
région vue ils ont compris qu'un miracle
avait eu lieu et que véritablement jésus
était ressuscité ils n'avaient pas
encore compris que d'après l'écriture
jésus devait ressuscité ensuite les
disciples repartir chez eux cependant
marie se tenait devant le tombeau et le
pleurer tout en pleurant elle se pencha
pour garder dans le tombeau elle vit
deux anges habillés de blanc assis à la
place où jésus avait été couché son
oncle kordjee gvt coucher l'un à la tête
autre pion aux autres pure
tu répondit parce qu'ils ont enlevé mon
seigneur je ne sais pas où ils ont mis
en disant cela il se retourna et vu
jésus debout mais je ne savais pas que
c'était si c'était lui jésus lui dit
femmes tout cas pleure tu qu'ils
cherchaient tu pour ça que c'était le
jardinier lui dit seigneur si c'est toi
qui l'emportait dit le foutu l'ami
j'irai le prendre je lui dit myriam la
sueur tournant des brus rabouni c'est à
dire m je lui dis ne me retient pas ne
me touche pas car je ne suis pas encore
remonté vers mon père mais va trouver
frère edddy là que je montre mon père et
votre père faire mon dieu et votre dieu
marie de l'acda de la magdala
l'annoncions dissiperait avait vu cela
et que le seigneur l'avait dit ces
choses maintenant je voudrais vous faire
remarquer plusieurs choses ici les
ossuaires ces petits coqs de terre dans
lequel on mettait les ossements des
décors quand la chaire avait été
décomposé d'autre part je voudrais vous
faire remarquer aussi
ses puts et s'est fracturé citer
qu'elles ont le rocher en eau ce sont
des endroits où on posait des poutres et
s'il ya un endroit qui pavés ça c'est
authentique ça veut dire qu'il y avait
ici un espace devant le tombeau qui
était assez vaste et qui était protégé
par un toit donc une structure
permanente ça veut dire qu'il y avait
ici des gens qui se rassemblent et et ça
jusqu'à à peu près 130 135 après jésus
christ la révolte de bar kokhba pourquoi
qui se rassembler ici et pouvoir se
rassembler tant ici manifestement une
communauté judéo chrétienne qui se
souvenait que c'était l'endroit où jésus
avait été déposé
c'est qu'ici vous avez grosso modo
l'image d'un dut meinau rattachant de
lier cette branche et le cheveu le
chandelier à sept branches à l'époque
c'était le symbole du christianisme ce
n'était pas la croix qui était symbole
du christianisme c'était le chandelier
vous avez ça dans l'apocalypse donc
l'argument selon lequel il n'y a pas de
tradition comme dans le cas du saint
sépulcre ne tient pas à passer de 135 ou
la communauté chrétienne a été dispersée
judéo chrétienne a été dispersée on a
oublié ce lieu qu'on a retrouvé avec
gordon mais disons dans les premières
décennies après la crucifixion jésus on
se souvenait que c'était là que jésus
avait été crucifié vraisemblablement
alors vous avez aussi un trouvailles et
vous dans la halle dans le tovo qui
permettait d'accéder directement c'est
ce qu'on appelle un effet slam l'âme de
la tombe c'était pour que la deûle à
l'âme du défunt puisse aller et venir
librement
et quand nous disons à vue des écrits du
début du 2ème siècle qui s'appelle l'a
dit hacker des douze apôtres qui nous
explique comment les premiers chrétiens
prenez la scène nous est dit ceci
quand vous vous a semblé vous reprendre
la scène que celui qui préside 10 quand
les espèces ont été consacrés si
quelqu'un ait pu qu'ils viennent si
quelqu'un ne l'est pas qu'ils se
repentent maranatha
pourquoi se repentir
marre parce que maranatha maranatha ça
signifie le seigneur vient
alors le cmuh revient aux derniers jours
mais pas nous montre que déjà plus que
cela dans ces tensions entre le passé 1
est venu passer la mort et la
résurrection de jésus est un arabe
d'événements avenue son retour aux
derniers jours il ya aujourd'hui il
vient le temps présent dans lequel nous
sommes
et ce temps là nous nous souvenons il
faut savoir que dans la mentalité brahic
on parlait hier de la pensée grecque de
la pensée juive vient dans la pensée
juive se souvenir c'est pas simplement
un mémorial quelque chose qui touche une
réalité qui est disparue qui est morte
mais c'est réactualisé l'événement
quand je me souviens de la mort et de la
résurrection de jésus en prenant le pen
20 je réactualise cet événement
et par conséquent dans ce moment de
sainte cène le seigneur est celui qui
vient il vient et il ne faut pas
simplement attendre sa venue au dernier
jour mais il faut attendre sa venue
maintenant il vient maintenant
je viens maintenant milieu de vous
et quand nous prenons le pain le vin de
la scène le seigneur est aussi présent
en tant que ressuscité qu'il était quand
il est venu au milieu de ses disciples
dans la chambre ou l'autre le soir de
pâques et qu'il viendra au dernier jour
il est aussi présent seulement la seule
différence c'est que pour l'heure voyons
pas nous ne pouvons pas le voir avec nos
yeux de cher tandis que quand ils
interviennent et joue tout a eu le verra
et que se passera-t-il aux derniers
jours quand le seigneur viendra est bien
de rendre à chacun selon ses oeuvres
il apportera la bénédiction juste et le
jugement méchant
or on nous dit que parce que certains
des corinthiens ont pris la sainte cène
indignement comme le rappelle a dit
hacker que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
beaucoup sont décédés à voir sont tombés
malades mêmes sont décédés avant leur
temps et pas le dis si nous nous jugeons
nous-mêmes ne serions pas juger mais
autrement si nous ne jugeons pas nous
mêmes nous sommes condamnés avec le
monde
pourquoi parce que quand le seigneur
viendra bien des jours il viendra comme
le juge le juge des derniers jours et
parce qu'il vient aujourd'hui et bien
déjà il est présent mieux de nous comme
celui qui me jugent et je dois me
présenter devant celui qui me jugent
donc je dois me jugez moi même pour ne
pas être jugés et condamnés que le monde
sera jugée au diané joue quand le
seigneur viendra
un autre une autre pensée avant que nous
ne partagions le pen 20 c'est lorsque
jésus chemine avec les disciples qui
vont à emmaüs
ces disciplines ne le reconnaissent pas
bien que jésus leur ouvre l'esprit pour
qu'ils comprennent les écritures et leur
explique en marchant tout ce qui le
concernait et il est très intéressant de
noter que c'est lorsque jésus prend le
pain et le vin rouge le pain le vin
qu'il reconnaisse
et
paradoxalement pendant tout le temps où
ils ne leur connaissait pas jésus était
avec eux et appartements ils
reconnaissent jésus disparaît devant
leurs yeux
et voyez vous
ça c'est aussi le sens de la scène
dans la sainte cène nous nous souvenons
sourire nous rendons présent le seigneur
il vient au milieu de nous et je crois
que là nous pouvons plus qu'un dans un
autre lieu évoquer ce souvenir est cette
réalité de sa présence le seigneur est
présent au milieu de nous en cet instant
parce qu'il est ressuscité il est
présent comme il était le soir de pâques
dans la chambre et autres comme il
l'était avec les disciples quand il a
pris la scène quand il a rompu le pain
les premières traces d'occupation
humaine dans cette région où la date
maison du xvème xvième siècle oui je
crie à l'époque où les phéniciens qui
étaient des pêcheurs déjà des marins
nous actons donc automatiquement des
pêcheurs également sont venus installer
sur les bords du lac ici des pêcheries
et ce sont les plus anciennes traces de
pêche qu'il ya dans cette région là les
phéniciens
avait donné à ce n'est à cet endroit
cela que le nom d'une de leurs divinités
qui était
joueuse de de lire d'où le nom de kinect
qui n'arrête ça veut dire la petite
fille mais c'était aussi le nom d'une
déesse de la pub enterrons finition de
cette période
et les phéniciens donc sont restés
quelques temps dans cette région là ils
ont d'ailleurs organisé aussi tout le
nord du pays et jusqu'à l'arrivée d
israël dans cette région
la région du clean air est est tombé par
le sort vous savez quand jésus a divisé
le pays entre les différentes tribus
comme le dit le livre du prophète isaïe
d'un chapitre 9 le peuple qui marche
dans les ténèbres voit une grande
lumière donc c'est la tribu de
naphtaline tribunal de naples où des
abus long qui se sont partagé cette
région a surtout la tribune installée et
dans le talmud c'est à dire les
commentaires rabbinique sur le la bible
il nous est dit que jésus ait à donner
le monopole de la pêche à la tribu de
nefta n'initie sur le lac les autres
tribus avaient le droit de pêcher mais
uniquement à la ligne et pêcher ou filet
c'était quelque chose qui était
l'apanage de la seule tribu de des frais
à partir donc de ce moment là il ya eu
des pêcheries juive se sont installés
compris le relais des pêcheries
phénicienne mais dans le canal
descendant d'écriture et brave de la
bible il ya assez peu de mention de la
pêche il ya un seul endroit où tout et
pour tout mais les questions de filet
c'est un livre du prophète habacuc mais
nous est dit que les babyloniens et
chaldéens convenir vers israël
sacrifie à l'infini comme si c'était un
dieu
par conséquent il n'y a pas eu un grand
développement de la pêche à cette
période là il faut attendre la période
du deuxième temps c'est à dire la
période du nouveau testament pour qu' il
y ait un développement important de la
pêche dans cette région nous sommes
issus en face de nous sur la rive
occidentale
il y a
de nombreuses pêcheries qui ceux qui ont
été installés à l'épreuve du deuxième
temps c'est à dire à l'époque romaine
empathie voulue est
ce la région où est issu du lac la
partie ouest du lac était
essentiellement une population juive
l'autre côté c'est à dire sur le à l'est
on avait une livre de divine que l'appel
a dit la décapole des cas police grecque
saluait les dix villes étaient devenues
autonomes des villes grecques autonome
donc non juive ce qui vous explique que
de l'autre côté du lac on y élever des
porcs tandis qu'ici on est évidemment
dans une région qui n'était pas peuplé
par des failles ah non je n'avais pas de
porc et la région de ghat darhaou
l'ajout de guerre à 5,90 différents sur
serge et nick se trouve de l'autre côté
du lac
il est à noter que le nombre des
pêcheries du côté grec du lac était
nettement moins développé que du côté
ouest roues que du côté juif et on
trouve pratiquement tous les kilomètres
de cette de cette région on trouve des
traces d'un port de pêche un port de
pêche très développé et la pêche était
très développé disons que il y avait là
des entreprises de pêche était
entreprise familiale avec des porcs
étaient très très nombreux et puis
procurer l'une des ressources
importantes du pays il y avait non
seulement des pêcheries mais il y avait
aussi des industries de conservation du
poisson de salaisons du poisson mais par
exemple la ville de magdala art et un
grand sens de la salaison du poisson pas
frais à la sardine
la sardine du lac étaient considérés
comme des petites façon fille camille
dans le las nouveau testament fait une
différence entre les grands et les
petits poissons par exemple dans le
récit d'un deuxième pêche miraculeuse
dans l'évangile de jean les questions de
la pêche miraculeuse qui avait eu lieu
deux cent cinquante trois grands
poissons
à côté de ces grands poissons
vous souvenez l'histoire du jeune garçon
qui avait cinq pains et des poissons
conserver à jésus pour multiplier ses
pas et ses poissons et nourrir une foule
de 5000 personnes
bien il est question qu'il avait à sa
disposition
cinq pains et deux petits poissons
le petit version vous mettez tout à
l'heure c'était forcément la salle du
bas saint jean c'est le poisson le plus
courant qu'on peut trouver saison le lag
vous pouvez trouver à cette époque là se
servait d'ordinaire pour
la nourriture des habitants du lac
saint jean était aussi commercialiser et
exporter qu'on a vu à partir de centres
comme celui de magdala dégoûté de ce
navet les grands pinceaux
alors viviane
trois grands types de poissons
essentiellement le grand pas ça le
premier c'est ce qu'on appelle
improprement le saint pierre de saint
pierre est ainsi nommé parce que nous
avons dans l'évangile un épisode où
jésus paient l'impôt donc avec un poids
à une pièce de monnaie qui a été trouvé
dans la gueule d'un poisson il ordonne à
pierre d'aller au lac de tirer à la
ligne le premier poisson qui lui a
effectué son bras sous la main de lui
ouvrir la bouche et dans la douche il
trouva devra payer l'impôt est pourvue
et où jésus
est aujourd'hui on déguste sur les bords
du live on appelle le saint pierre de
saint pierre son nom véritable c'est le
tilapia
si la pièce est un poisson tropical
parce que si on aère un climat quasi
tropicale
et surtout très très connu par les
africains les accus les africains
connaissent très bien sûr moi ça la
seule chose qu'on peut dire c'est que ce
poisson là n'est pas le saint pierre
pour une bonne et simple raison vous ne
prendrez jamais et il a bien à l'hameçon
il ne faudra jamais à l'hameçon parce
que la femelle
utilise sa gueule pour garder ses yeux
quand jusqu'à ce que c'était que nous
les petits restent dans le la bouche de
la maman n'est pas conséquent jamais
ainsi la pierre nous mordre à l'hameçon
ce poisson dont il est considéré comme
l'un des plats sont les plus fins et les
plus savoureux qu'il ya ici dans le lac
mais le poisson saint pierre mondy cette
façon dans lequel il y avait à presse
donnée raisonnablement une des
différentes sortes on écarte cette
mesure via plusieurs variétés de cas qui
elles aussi sont considérés comme des
grands pinceaux et puis il ya un autre
grand poisson que l'on trouve dans cette
région là c'est le poisson-chat
poisson chat il est extrêmement
savoureux aussi mais il n'est pas
consommée par les juifs parce que c'est
un poisson non casher c'est un poisson
effet qu'il n'a pas des cayes elle
savait que selon les lois de bioéthique
il est interdit de consommer 1 comme un
juif des poissons sans est calme ça vous
explique la parabole du film et qu'il
retrouve dans le chapitre xiii de
l'évangile de matthieu
en fait dans les évangiles sont nommés
quatre types différents de filet à 4
mots grecs différents pour désigner
quatre types de filets mais la plupart
des traducteurs qui n'était pas du tout
et pêcheurs il ne connaissait rien à la
pêche sous par gerald casser la tête ces
quatre mots là et les autres à nous de
simplement par des filets c'est bien
qu'on n'est pas plus avancé avez vous
parlé rapidement de ces quatre types de
finir premier de ses filets c'est celui
dont il est question dans ce chapitre
xiii de l'évangile de marc
j'ai dit que le royaume des cieux est
semblable filet et que des pêcheurs ont
jeté dans la mer on ramène le filet sur
le rivage mais on fait le tri des
personnes alors ce poids sur ce filet
c'est ce qu'on appelle la scène c'est un
fait mais le faire entre 150 et 200
mètres de long et rectangulaire
et il est d'une part dans la partie
supérieure il y à des flotteurs
et la partie inférieure de la délaisse
de telle façon que quand il est mouillé
dans la mer il fasse une murale
verticale
aujourd'hui on utilisait encore il ya
peu plus encore ce fils et en afrique en
particulier
mais on utilisait des restes du plomb
à l'époque de nouveau testament on
n'utilisait pas de l'est de plomb c'est
mon ami le regretté mendels noon étaient
50 ans pêcheur dans le lac et
redécouvert l'énigme
l'a découvert sur tous les bords du lac
que vous avez peut-être pouvoir en
trouver celle de la chance des pierres
percées qui servait de l'est
[Musique]
la plupart des foules même ignoré ce
phénomène là dans la mesure où on
pensait que si les trous qu'il y avait
dans le dans les rivières
lacs ramène sur la belge notamment après
le temps de tempête
était de tout naturel
convoqué par l'érosion en réalité mais
ne nous l'a prouvé qu'il en était rien
que c'était d'être ou artificiels on va
très bien l'endroit où ils ont été
percés nous on va très bien
l'usure de la corde on fondait ses
pierres dont certains étaient des silex
vous savez que le silex c'est une pièce
extrêmement dure
et on recense élevé quand on avait percé
un trou on s'en servait pour lester les
filets le filet était replié en
accordéon et il était manoeuvré par deux
équipes munich puis rester sur la terre
ferme et qui est un moyen d'une pêche
tenait une fusée verticale et puis une
deuxième équipe qui était sur le bateau
sur lequel était repliée le filet en
accordéon faisait tout à l'heure qui
partait perpendiculairement au visage et
qui moulienne filet derrière lui
lorsque le fils était totalement déployé
nous permet régulièrement à la côte le
bateau faisait 1 90 2 v m il tirait le
filet derrière lui qui ramassait donc
que tout ce qu'il y avait dans la mer et
ensuite ils arrivent et 150 mètres plus
loin où 200 mètres plus loin sur le
rivage ont tiré le filet sur le rivage
on faisait le tri des poissons on
faisait le tri notamment entre les
poissons cacher et puis les poissons
chats qui était non casher et fêter
rejeter à la mer
et ça vous explique justement que cette
image que jésus crois que nous voyons
mme dedieu et comme ce filet qui a été
jeté dans la mer qui ramasse toutes
sortes de poissons savent la parole de
dieu s'adresse à tous les hommes
si c'est un temps de grâce et un ton
dieu suspend ses jugements
mais il y aura un deuxième temps où le
filet sera ramenée sur le solde ce sera
le jugement années durant le tri entre
les justes et les injustes ceux qui ont
reçu la parole de dieu mais ce qui ne
leur ont pas reçu
deuxième type de fines et c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'épervier est férié c'est un
filet en forme de cloche
il est aussi lesté ne s'appartient fait
inférieure et c'est un filet qui est
d'utiliser l'eau loin de la côte les
manoeuvrer par par un seul homme il ya
un geste très spécial fou que quand on
jette le feeling se déploie et il en
cage en quelque sorte une partie de la
mer
le poisson n'a pas le temps de partir et
se trouve prisonnier à l'intérieur de
cette cloche et l'on plonge
pour attacher ensuite le bas du filet on
ramène l'ensemble et puis on l'a aussi
on fait le tri du poisson dans les mêmes
conditions que celles que nous avons
évoqué tout à l'heure remarquons que
c'était ce genre de fille dès que que
claire manoeuvrer continuité d'un
deuxième multiplication des pains cas il
nous est dit que quand il est on lui a
dit que c'était jésus qui étaient là et
pris son vêtement c'est à dire une
espèce de slips parce qu'il était nu il
était nu parce qu'il plongeait pour
attacher les pv au bas de combat deux du
fine et
troisième filet c'est ce qu'on appelle
le fus les vérandas
il a deux formula 2 2 deux variétés de
ce filet très exactement
on appelle le sud est où le filet
véranda ou le très mal très mal ainsi
nommée parce que c'est un filet à 3
miles aumônerie enfin ce sont trois fils
et qui sont accolés les uns aux autres
avec des mailles de différents calibres
ce filet il est embarqué sur un bateau
qui mouille en cercle comme ça en cercle
fermé ça veut dire qu'il engage une
partie de la mer
et les bacs reste à l'intérieur du
cercle et quand le filet a complètement
été mauvais on fait le maximum de bruit
on tape on crie ses terres à des fins
effrayer le poisson le poisson pas dans
toutes les directions et forcément
il va rencontrer le filet c'est un
obstacle il arrive arrive dans la
première manche du filet il s'affole ni
ce débat plus il est bas plus il sent
période l'ific dans le deuxième filet
s'il ne parvient pas c'est passé
deuxième filet il trouve un troisième
filet donc il a loupé pratiquement
aucune chance d'échapper au bout de
quelques temps on relève le filet on
récupère les poissons ainsi 1,6 ainsi
réaliser maintenant le poisson il a une
autre possibilité c'est qu'il peut
sauter par dessus les
alors mon emploi un quatrième type de
fille le filet véranda c'est un
travail un bon port un peu plus
sophistiqué dans lequel sur lequel sur
mon ami un autre filet en forme de toi
si vous voulez pour empêcher nos
passions de sauter par dessus
donc si vous voulez voilà
essentiellement les quatre types de
filets qui était employé par les
pêcheries du lac
maintenant il y avait également verra
tout à la prostate après ça je le
réserve pour tout à l'heure je vous
raconterai tout puisqu'il vient d en
face de vous si regardez
vous avez cet éperon rocheux là on est
arrivé par ailleurs d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'on appelle les camps de
routine
ça il ya eu là
en 1992
une célèbre bataille entre les croisés
et saladin
dans cette région là
les croisés ont subi formidable défaite
qui leur a fait perdre le royaume de
jérusalem ça a été la fin de la première
croisade
et croisés avaient rassemblé toutes
leurs carabines pratiquement toutes
leurs armes et ou du chevalier de terre
sainte s'étaient rassemblés à accous
saint jean d'âcre pour récupérer ici la
femme de raymonde toulouse qui avait été
emprisonné par saladin tibériade
et
saladin avait tendu un piège aux ont
croisé danser dans ce défilé se défient
des décors de poutine
quand il est chaud et c'était en plein
mois de juillet les chevaliers avait
cheveux chevauchée extrêmement assemble
les il avait perdu toutes les réserves
d'eau avait été
transpercée par les flèches des archers
arabes qui les a appelés il n'avait
qu'un seul but c'était arrivé au lac
pour moi et quand ils sont arrivés dans
ce défilé ils ont vu le lac pour eux
c'était absolument magnifique mais ils
ont constaté que les arabes barrer la
route
paraît complètement là toute la largeur
du défilé qu'à cela ne tienne on emploie
la tactique de venice en faisant des
crasses tous les ans ça va
c'était la technique de la chasse des
chevaliers cuirassé croisés mais en
général cette charge là elle est
irrésistible
en plus de ça il y avait de la pente que
vous voyez donc avait tout pour pouvoir
réussir et la charge est parti à toute
vitesse et quand elle est arrivée au
niveau des délits
saladin fait ouvrir les rangs et la
charge croisé est passé dans le vide et
quand la ksa 3 a été passé salade à fait
refermée les rangs
et l'écran les chevaliers étaient coupés
de leurs gendarmes ça veut dire de
l'infanterie petit rester de côté
tout pendant toute la journée ils ont
essayé de charger à contreportes vous
imaginez ce que ça veut dire charger à
contretemps
ça a été l'échec et le soir alors un
cheval qui était tombé à terre c'est un
chevalier fischer n'émet pas se relever
et tous les chevaliers terre sainte
était as fait tes morts c'est bien
caveau du chenal est été ouverte avant
cela d'un sans le moindre combat c'est
là aussi qu'il ya eu un épisode de la
tempête apaisée et de jésus marchant sur
les eaux avait une action sur la mer
c'est
c'est quelque chose évidemment puis nous
sommes tout à fait incroyable d'imaginer
qu'il puisse avoir des tempêtes
dangereux sur ce lac
mais effectivement en hiver en
particulier il peut s'avérer il peut
s'élever des tempêtes extrêmement brutal
extrêmement violent que j'aie vu une
fois des vagues qui déferlaient sur la
promenade de tibériade que telle manière
que même les cafés les bistrots qui
avaient leurs terrasses la bande et des
ménages est la leur
star les deux chaînes elle est rentrée à
l'intérieur tellement la villa
violence du courant était forte ce matin
ce même jour le soir jésus leur dit
passion de l'autre bord
après avoir envoyé la foule il
l'emmenait dans la barque où il se
trouvait il y avait aussi d'autres bacs
avec lui il se leva un grand tourbillon
et les feux se jeter dans la bas au
point qu'elle se remplissait déjà en
verra ça tout à l'heure pour ça sur le
bateau damas et lui donnait à la poupe
sur le plus sain et de réveiller le dire
m ne t'inquiète pas de ce que
l'opération s'étant réveillée menaçable
devant aider et la mer et dissidences
tétouan et le vent c'est ça lutins grand
calme puis il leur dit pourquoi avez
vous eu peur comment avez-vous points
deux fois il faut saisir une grande
frayeur et se dire les autres quel est
donc celui ci a qui obéissent même le
vent et la mer
comme jésus se trouvait près du lac tout
gêné s'arrête et que la foule se
pressait autour de lui pour entendre la
parole de dieu
il vit au bord du lac de ba d'où les
pêcheurs étaient descendus pour laver
leur filet il monta dans l'une de ces
bacs étaient assis vent et le pria de
s'éloigner un peu de la terre puisse
acia et de la batterie l'enseigné la
foule parce qu'il eut cessé de parler
dit à simon avant son plein et jetez vos
filets pour pêcher s'ils m'ont répondu m
nous avons travaillé toute la nuit sans
rien prend mais sur ta parole je
jetterai le fus des néants je t ai pris
une grande quantité de poissons et leurs
filets seront paix mais fait signe à
leurs compagnons qui étaient dans une
autre base de venir les aider il vint et
remplir les deux vagues au point qu'elle
s'enfonçait quand il veut cela pierre
tombale ou genou de jésus et du seigneur
retire toi de moi parce que je suis un
empêcheur à l'épouvantail l'ua avait
saisi et ainsi tout ce qui était à lui
vécu à cause de la pêche qu'ils avaient
fait en était de même de jacques de jean
phi zébédée associé de simon alors j'ai
juste à simon ne craint pas désormais tu
seras pêcheurs d'hommes et ont ramené
les bacs sur la terre il est certes ou
et je suivais
beaucoup choses se sont passées sur ce
lac
et nous sommes vraiment là au centre
coeur même de les manger
la russie nous sommes sur l'emplacement
du port de tapera des pains des nombreux
ports de fait ce qu'il y avait sur la
rive occidentale du lac et vous pouvez
très bien ici voir les jeter du hac
regardez là bas là où sont les gens vous
avez cette jetée qui s'avance dans la
mer vous la devinez sous l'os a fait un
espèce de nuit cercle comme ça mais ça
vient à peu près à ce niveau là pour
rejoindre ici l'autre jeter que vous
avez sur la droite qui elle aussi
s'avance dans la mer et qui délimite
l'entrée du port donc c'était importe
qu'ils étaient protégés et vous avez ici
sont à peine une promenade avec des
pierres de basalte qui rejoint cette cet
endroit là et qui se prolonge jusqu'à
peu jusqu'à cap airnow de telle sorte
que tapera était en réalité l'avant-port
de cas de cap airnow et là vous avez des
idées des scènes évangélique nombreuses
qui se sont réalisés dans cet endroit là
la première c'est quand jésus arrive
depuis nazareth il va appeler les
premiers disciples ici à tapera commune
marcher le long de la mer il vit jean
jacques lé fils de zébédée qui étaient
là dans une barque et les appels en
disant suivez moi je ferais pêcheurs
d'hommes on a lu ce matin le texte où
jésus rencontre des disciples qui sont
en train de nettoyer de laver le filet
qui peut faire jusqu'à 200 mètres de
long et après 12 séances de pêche en
général le filet était un peu endommagé
plus ou moins ça dépend des des
obstacles rencontrés dans la mer et
quand tu es la pêche était terminée ont
tiré le filet sur la terre on l'étalé
pour le sécher et éventuellement pour le
réparer il fallait évidemment une grande
surface pourrait aller enfiler plusieurs
filets s'il y avait plusieurs
entreprises de pêche qui se trouvaient
dans cette annonce dans le même port il
fallait une grande surface pour pouvoir
étaler les filets et on s'était sur la
promenade que ça se passait donc l'appel
du disciple de jésus a eu lieu là bas
donc on est vraiment ici dans un lieu
absolument évangélique
mais dans une région ici volcanique et
par conséquent un gain d eau thermale
des eaux chaudes qui se déverse dans le
lac directement en sortant de la
montagne si bien qu ici ça donne un des
endroits les plus chauds du lac et ça
permet aux poissons
de venir se réfugier là l'hiver a vu que
les poissons du lac sont des poissons
qui sont essentiellement des poissons de
type tropicaux le tilapia par exemple
l'été ça va très bien ils sont tout à
fait à l'aise ici l'hiver c'est un peu
moins parce que c'est quand même pas
tout à fait l'intérim a tropical et les
poissons se rassemblent ici donc divers
et notamment du vin ce moment où le
poisson vient freiner mais par
conséquent c'est un des endroits les
plus poissonneuses du lac c'est la
raison pour laquelle on pense que c'est
dans cet endroit là que lui et la pêche
miraculeuse
à pêche miraculeuse elle n'est pas
miraculeuse tant par la quantité de
poissons crise qui a été prise ça aussi
mais surtout par le fait que ces 7 est
prise deux jours parce que à l'époque on
avait défilé de coton et les filets de
coton sont visibles l'eau est tellement
transparente que le poisson va venir le
filet donc quand le jour élevé à
l'époque on n'avait aucune chance de
pouvoir pêcher le moindre poisson de
façon s'enfuit avant que le filet réussi
à l'atteindre
aujourd'hui on n'a plus ces problèmes là
parce qu'on est des défilés de nylon si
bien que le poisson ne voit pas venir de
chez les mais à l'époque c'était quelque
chose d'important et là donc on est dans
ce site qui était le sud de la pêche
miraculeuse donc c'est avancer voyez
vous ces avancées dans la mer sur la
barque pourquoi parce que l'eau porte la
voix comme une espèce de haut parleurs
naturel et après donc il a demandé à ses
disciples de jeter le vilain dans la mer
alors que le jour été levée depuis très
longtemps donc c'est un des endroits les
plus poissonneuses du lac
vous avez un autre lieu qui est aussi
poissonneux c'est de l'autre côté
exactement presque en face de nous
s'appelle le site de course il m'a posé
ce matin la question où est ce qu a eu
lieu le miracle de la guérison du
procédé par une légion de démons qui se
sont enfuis pendant dix ans des ports et
bien c'est justement là bas c'est
justement en face
on a retrouvé l'endroit l'escarpement où
les porcs se sont jetés dans le lac dans
la retrouver en particulier une église
byzantine qui commémore l'événement donc
on est sûr que c'est à cet endroit là
qu'a eu lieu donc le
le miracle des zags raison de cet homme
qui est qualifié de gars assémien où
j'ai rassegna ghaddar à ceyrat match
khadr qui se trouve au sud du lac et
géra ça c'est la jerash moderne qui se
trouvant toujours du côté du côté
jordanien de la région mais toute cette
région là était une religion païenne on
l'a vu ce matin parce que c'était une
région qui était composé d'une ligue de
10 villes qu'était autonome à l'inter de
l'ampli roma ils étaient des villes
grecques quand il si bien que là bas on
élevait des ports tandis qu'ici on
élevait pas de porc sur la rive
occidentale
parce que c'était une mûre et une rive
qui était une ruse juive
la galilée vosges unique est toute
petite elle va depuis tibériade qui
n'est jamais citée dans la bible si ce
n'est une fois dans l'évangile de jean
mais qu dans laquelle jésus pas
apparemment n'est jamais entré parce que
tibériade était une ville païenne
c'était une ville qui est interdite aux
juifs mais jésus est respecté à fond
cette prescription là donc ça va deux
plus libéré yade vague dallas disons
plus exactement jusqu'à courcy ça c'est
le pays évangélique donc c'est tout
petit prix vous ans quand on dit
l'évangile ma l'impression que jésus
faisait des des dizaines voire des
centaines de kilomètres prévoyez-vous
c'est tout petit
maintenant dernier point vous avez une
petite chapelle là bas sont à quai et en
chasser un rocher selon une tradition
qui remonte à l'époque du croisy vous
savez des croisés et se déplacer à pied
ou se déplacer en à cheval alors pour
réduire les frais de déplacement ils ont
réduit ils ont tous rassemblés les lieux
saints dans un même dans un même
périmètre
et là vous avez donc un petit peu plus
bas vous avez l'endroit de la
multiplication des pains et si vous avez
l'endroit la deuxième pêche miraculeuse
à première pêche à deuxième pêche
miraculeuse à où jésus a récupéré vous
plutôt pierre a récupéré les 153 grands
poissons dont on parlait ce matin et là
il a donc entendu jésus lui dire à trois
reprises paie mes brebis
et on appelle ça la primauté de pierre
des catholiques à peut s'attribuer la
primauté de plaine et dans cette
chapelle vous avez un rocher qui est
enchâssé en appelle même sacristie en
latin ça signifie la table du christ
c'est l'endroit où quand jésus avait
préparé le repas pour ses disciples
vraiment de la pêche miraculeuse et sur
la droite dans un jardin vous avez une
statue représente jésus disons à pierre
tu éclaires
c'est ce qu'on appelle à une mise après
la primauté de près alors que faut-il
penser de ces trois cette reddition
c'est du bison pure et simple
parce que la multiplication n'a pas pu
avoir lieu ici nous est dit dans
l'évangile que la multiplication des
pains de vue dans un endroit désert or
ici ce n'était pas un endroit désert
c'était un lieux surpeuplés au contraire
donc c'est une tradition issue qui n'est
pas public est mon ami mais là nous ne
pensait que la multiplication des pains
avaient eu lieu de l'autre côté du
lac la région au delà de bayside à
l'appel le désert de belles saïda quant
à la deuxième place miraculeuse ce n'est
pas impossible mais gros point
d'interrogation
par contre la première pêche miraculeuse
a vu ici ça c'est sûr
si on se trouve dans un des endroits les
plus sûrs votre point de vue
authenticité du site
on est tout simplement ici à côté de la
maison de pierre
l'endroit où jésus avait pris pension
pendant qu'il habitait avec internat
nous on a vu tout à l'endroit où il a
appelé les disciples assassin le suivre
et pierre lui a ouvert sa maison dont
qui l'a aidé à se sublimer il a connu
une suite à l'it et le spi thaïs et
d'amusant de claix bon ce sont des fous
est effectuée ici par les franciscains
et on a retrouvé comme vous le voyez ici
des ruines d'une ville qui est une ville
romaine en basalte noir avec des pierres
en général drut ou très peu à gré en
général et c'est une ville qui est bâti
sur le modèle roma c'est à dire les
modèles on appelle les insu l'est c'est
à dire les hinault qui sont délimités
par des rues qui se coupe à angle droit
vous pouvez recevoir laisser une rue
avec et qui rejoignent et la route
principale qui est enfoui sous la
là les modernes là et qui servait donc à
relier la synagogue que là bas qui était
le bâtiment le plus important de la
ville au port qui se trouvent de l'autre
côté et on a retrouvé ici des maisons
que vous verrez si des maisons très
simples qui sont en hausse certains sont
tentés battu vous pouvez le voir ici
donc sont grossièrement pavé ce sont des
maisons qui sont très simples qui sont
des maisons
de gens qui sont quand même pas
tellement tellement fortunés qui
sont des maisons en général à
des gens une pièce ou deux spas pièces
qui sont tournés autour intérieur et si
vous voyez le climat comme il est c'est
un climat tropical il pleut très
rarement et par conséquent la vie se
déroulait en dehors plutôt que d'en à
l'intérieur c'est pour ça que finalement
on n'aménage et pas d'une manière
luxueuse intérieur des maisons est au
dessus on verra tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait des escaliers qui permettait de
monter sur le toit un toit qui était
fait en branchages qui servait de
poutres et entre les guerres entre
lesquels on mettait une espèce de
mélange de boue concasser avec de la
paille qui
été relativement facile à percer ce qui
vous explique l'épisode du paralytique
qui a été gris qui a été donc
transportés ici c'est à cet endroit là
que c'est que cela s'est accompli alors
remarqué ou si vous avez des maisons qui
sont construites femme près tous sur le
même modèle maintenant vous avez ici
cette structure qui est une structure
très particulière ça c'est le plan ici
de l'ensemble que nous voyons là et vous
avez ici
la représentation de ceux de cette
structure est une structure octogonale
que vous pouvez le voir et on vous a
expliqué que l'archéologie ici dans le
pays les villes sont construites par
strates les unes sur les autres qui sont
superposées les unes sur les autres
parce que finalement
l'emplacement d'une insulte et un
emplacement a été choisi pour les
conditions
optimum donc quand on détruit c'est pour
reconstruire ensuite est le meilleur
endroit pour construire c'est celui où
on a détruit donc on va reconstruire à
l'endroit où on a détruit si bien que
vous avez plusieurs couches qui se sent
plus les unes sur les autres ici nous
avons quatre strates dans ces structures
là la strate supérieure à 2 3 et 4 ce
qui est intéressant et c'est justement
cet octogone fait il trouvait le premier
la octogone c'est une c'est une église
byzantine l'éminente a construit en
forme de tôle c'est par exemple si la
structure de la sonapi la mosquée d'omar
à jérusalem que tu annules togo
également donc c'est sainte hélène la
mère de constanta
quand l'empiré devenu chrétien et noir
c'est christianisé disons les choses
comme ça c'est plus exact que donc la
mêlée venu ici au pèlerinage c'est la
première pèlerine
chrétienne et surtout les emplacements
des usa elle a récupéré les traditions
elle a construit des églises byzantines
main donc
a construit cet endroit là parce que là
il y avait certainement un lieu ça très
important quelque chose que l'on a voulu
mettre en valeur qu'elle a voulu
sacralisé on retrouve aussi des couches
de strates au sujet de cette basilique
byzantine et puis en dessous vous avez
une autre structure et vous arriver
ensuite à une quatrième structure et là
on arrive au sol vierge la structure
numéro un reprenons ça maintenant dans
l'ordre chronologique la plus ancienne
par conséquent donc date de l'époque
romaine dont à l'époque de jésus et là
vous avez
d une maison une maison toute simple
qu'est ce qu'une maison pêcheurs comme
on le sait parce qu'elle n'était pas
pavée d'abord et on a trouvé des
hameçons et des instruments de pêche
donc on est sûr que c'était une maison
de pêcheur deuxième période 4e siècle
c'est-à-dire au début de lettres de la
chrétienne
ces structures et a grandi on a pavé
l'ensemble qui était à terre battue et
tout autour il ya des espèces de banc
qui délimite ce qu'on appelle le bonus
ecclesia c'est à dire une maison
d'église
les premiers chrétiens se rassemble et
non pas dans des bâtiments ce n'est qu'à
partir à passer du 4e siècle d'ailleurs
comme ça qu'on appelle des bases uniques
c'est à dire des lieux de culte
chrétiens
auparavant c'est dans des maisons
privées donc ici manifestement ce qui
s'est produit c'est que une maison
privée a été transférée transféré en
maison d'église
manifestement pour la communauté
chrétienne qui se rassemblaient
pourquoi on a choisi cette maison là et
pas celle là
pourquoi sainte-hélène at-elle sacralisé
cette maison là et pas celle là
et bien parce que effectivement la
tradition avait gardé l'idée que c'était
la maison de pierre
dans laquelle jésus avait
lui avaient pratiqué beaucoup de c2c
miracle donc ici on est sûr que l'on est
vraiment dans cet endroit que l'évangile
de marc capelle la maison tout
simplement c'était
la maison de jésus en quelque sorte et
marque évoque une grande semaine que
jésus passa qu'aperam c'est le premier
chapitre de son livre et là il nous
montre jésus qui entrent dans la
synagogue le shabbat il arrive un
shabbat il entre dans la synagogue mirer
dans un instant en sortant la synagogue
ils seront ici dans la maison caire où
il a même permis d'éclairer malade il va
guérir label la belle-mère et elle va le
servir et puis évidemment cette ce
miracle se répandre dans une traînée de
poudre et
le soir donc au coucher du soleil les
malades vont se rassembler ici sur
devant la halle à la maison de pierre
pourquoi attendons la fin de saison le
coucher du soleil pour amener les
malades à jésus parce que c'est la fin
du shabbat on ne veut pas que j'allais
le shabbat ont changé dû acquérir les
gens le jour du shabbat
bon c'est aussi
le
l'histoire de ce paralytique on a évoqué
tout à l'heure la maison et surpeuplé
voyez-vous s'est rapidement fait parce
que c'est tellement
l'image d'une ces maisons là et donc les
les amis de cette 7ème n'arrivent pas à
accéder jusqu'à jésus qui montent sur le
toit vous avez tout à le voir ici sur la
droite un escalier qui permettait
d'accéder sur le toit et là ils vont
percer le toit ce qui est relativement
facile j'expliquerai pourquoi tout à
l'heure et ils vont descendre de
paralyser vous prie jésus jésus donc va
guérir ce paralytique en pardonnant ses
bûchers voilà ici on est dans un endroit
les plus authentiques qu'ils soient au
point de vue par feu le chou
kpn homme était
situé à une frontière
entre d'une part les états de redon
petits passent et les états deux rôles
philippe et qu'est ce que c'est que ces
gens là et bien c'est disons les fils
des road le grand héros de legrand c'est
l'assassin des enfants de btm et à sa
mort donc son son royaume a été divisée
en quatre par les romains
la judée a été jugé insuffisant ce qui
s'appelait arqués la hausse la galilée
et la paire est c'est à dire la
transjordanie juive ont été accordés à
hérode antipas cela ça saint jean
baptiste et puis au delà de cap airnow
de l'autre côté là bas c'était les états
d'un autre fils des rôles qui s'appelait
philippe se fait qu'un père n'en mettais
une ville frontière ce qui vous explique
pourquoi il y avait un bureau de douane
qui était présidée par les i mathieu
l'évangéliste du même nom qui sait et
est originaire de captain america
étaient appelés à elle comme étant un
disciple de jésus et qui est devenu
l'auteur de l'évangile de matthieu
il y avait aussi à cause de cette même
raison il a vu une garnison romaine côté
dirigée par un centurion et le centurion
du cac perd nos hommes était ce qu'on
appelle un crédit en dieu c'est à dire
un païen
qui sans embrasser le judaïsme dans sa
totalité notamment par la circoncision
c'était quelqu'un qui s'approchait du
judaïsme et pratiquer les principaux
préceptes du judaïsme il se dit que dans
sa piété son aile pour le judaïsme ce
centurion de ses propres tenues avait
construit une synagogue ohel
etc se sentent nuit dont jésus qui rira
le fils malade ou le serviteur il est de
tradition dans les évangiles
en tout cas il a été l'objet d'un
miracle du jésus il a conçu une
synagogue cette synagogue n'est pas
celle là cette synagogue on regrette une
synagogue qui date de l'époque byzantine
et qui est beaucoup plus tard dire que
le village que voyez là vous vous
apercevez d'abord différence énorme dans
le style architectural et dans les
pierres là on a du basalte noir là on a
du calcaire donc ce sont deux époques
totalement différente mais en fouillant
en dessous de cette synagogue du
creusage du 4e siècle on trouve le même
style que celui que vous avez là en
basalte noir
là ce sont les fondations d'une
synagogue est plus ancienne que celle là
et que la synagogue que jésus a connu la
synagogue a été construite à ce fameux
centurion
et plus tard donc quand le temple sera
détruit
contrairement à ce qu'on croit
sap a été la fin de l'époque le mans
israélite ici on
en terre d'israël la judée a été a
beaucoup souffert de la grande révolte
contre les romains
mais la galerie nettement moins en
galilée il ya eu une seule bataille j'ai
vraiment sanglante c'était la bataille
de magdala la bataille du lac et en
dehors de cela c'est de la gaminerie
s'est soumise aux romains donc elle a
pratiquement peu souffert de ce qui
s'était passé si bien que après la
destruction du temple
là le centre de centre névralgique le
centre spirituel du judaïsme
a fini par se transporter en gallier
notamment ici à tibériade qui était une
ville pas guen et qui est devenu par un
étrange tour de passe-passe la quatrième
ville sainte d'israël et par conséquent
à l'époque byzantine
l'époque jean-michel du talmud on
appelle ça en hébreu
vous avez ici une explosion très
important d'une vie spirituelle juive
extrêmement florissante et notamment une
construction de superbes synagogue dont
celle là ça c'est une des ddt des
synagogues n'est pas la seule à de très
nombreuses synagogues qui sont
construites ici aussi à cette période
byzantine et qui montre qu'il y avait
une vitalité très importante qui va
durer jusque pratiquement la conquête
arabe ils se rendirent à capharnaüm
dès le jour du shabbat jésus entra dans
la synagogue
ici et il se met à enseigner on était
frappé de son enseignement car ils ont
tenu avec autorité non pas comme un
spécialiste de la loi
traduction discutable il y avait dans
leurs synagogues un homme qui avait un
esprit un put il s'écrira que nous veut
tu jésus de nazareth
es tu venu pour nous perdre
je sais qui tu es le saindoux dure je
veux une menace en disant tétouan et
sort de cet homme
esprits impurs sortie de cet homme en
secouant violemment en plus sans un
grand cris tout sursis et frier qui se
demandaient les autres qu'est ce que
ceux ci quel est ce nouvel enseignement
il commande avec l'autorité même aux
esprits impurs ils obéissent et sa
réputation gagner aussitôt toute la
région d'agadez
en sortant des sinagots ils se rendirent
avec jacques et jean la maison de ciment
et d'andré la belle mère de pierre était
couché avec de la fièvre site où on
parle à des lâchers zus approchait la
fil avait lui prenant la main en
annonçant la chèvre la quitta plus il se
met à son service
le soir après le coucher du soleil on
vermine à tous les mêmes malades et les
démoniaques toute la ville était
rassemblée devant la porte
geri beaucoup de personnes qui
souffraient de diverses maladies chasse
aussi beaucoup de dimanche il ne
permettait pas de parler parce qu'il ne
connaissait
quelques jours après jésus revint avec
internat hommes ont appris qu'ils
étaient à la maison et vous la maison
tout simplement
un si grand nombre de personnes se
rassemblaient qu'il n'avait plus de
place pas même devant la porte et leur
annoncer la parole on va lui amener un
paralysé porté par quatre hommes comme
il ne pouvait pas l'aborder à cause de
la foule ils découvrirent le toit
au-dessus endroit il se tenait
descendirent par cette ouverture de
branca sur lequel le paralytique était
couchée rayon leur foi jésus était
paralysée mon enfant est pêché deux sont
pardonnés il y avait là quelques
spécialistes de la loi qui était assise
qui se diront eux mêmes pourquoi cet
homme parle de génocide asem qui peut
pardonner les péchés si ce n'est dieu
seul je suis aussitôt dans son esprit
qu'il raisonne ainsi ont eux mêmes leur
dis pourquoi raisonnée vous ainsi dans
vos coeurs qu'est ce qui est plus facile
de dire au paralytique tes péchés sont
pardonnés ou restera prends ton
brancards et marche afin que vous
sachiez le fils de l'ama sur la terre le
pouvoir de pardonner les péchés je te le
donne dutil au paralytique laisse toi
prends conduit retourne chez toi citoyen
se leva a pris son lit est sorti devant
tout le monde sans qu'ils aient tous
étonnés et célébrer la gloire de dieu en
disant n'avons jamais rien vu de pareil
mais nous sommes ici devant le site de
mai o qui est un des plus importants
d'israël parce que il est en quelque
sorte le verrou stratégique du pays il
est au débouché de d'un défilé qui
s'appelle loi diarra n'a pas dire aux
nombreux qui permet de communiquer
l'immense plaine d'israël devant la dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons également
ici
avec la plaine côtière mais cette passe
de mes vidéos comme on l'appelle est
situé d'entre d'une part le massif du
carmel à l'ouest et des montagnes de
nefta ni à l'est c'est deux chaînes de
montagnes forment une véritable barrière
naturelle qui empêche le passage entre
le nord et le sud du pays et par
conséquent
il n'y a qu'un seul voix eu un seul
passage ce torrent à sec qui passe entre
ces deux blocs de montagne la chaîne du
carmel et la chaîne de montagnes de
nesta lui c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles depuis la plus haute
antiquité il ya toujours eu ici une
forteresse qui contrôle cette passe et
qui la bloque éventuellement vis-à-vis
des adversaires et là il ya eu depuis
les temps immémoriaux des combats pour
le contrôle de cette passe depuis
l'époque du pharaon trou de metz troyes
au xvième siècle avant jésus-christ
jusqu'en 1948 la bataille pour
l'indépendance du pays d'israël sans
parler du en 1917 la campagne générale
allenby qui avait remporté ici la
victoire qui lui avait ouvert la porte
le chemin le chemin de damas
précisément à cause de l'importance
stratégique de cet endroit
de telles que l'on voit ici est
constitué de 22 villes superposées les
unes sur les autres pendant toute
l'époque historique ce site a été occupé
jusqu'à sa son abandon après la chute de
jérusalem en 586 avant jésus-christ et
c'est une raison pour laquelle aussi ce
site qui a été occupée sans interruption
pendant tout n'est pas l'époque
historique et la clé stratégique du pays
d'israël donc c'est vraiment un endroit
stratégique et majeur et essentiel pour
la compréhension de toute l'histoire
biblique
découverts c'est que c'était une
idéologie qui était une jjp sienne c'est
en égypte qu'on trouve des bas-reliefs
on voit le pharaon en train de fouler
ses ennemis sous ses pieds on retrouve
cette idée aussi donc ah c'est toi ma
droite 1910 jusqu'à ce que j'ai fait de
taizé mitton marche presque tu foule aux
pieds donc tes ennemis est
là et on aurait donc ici une preuve que
et à ceux qui ont construit cette
structure qui est unique on ne connaît
dans aucune autre civilisation au monde
on ne connaît une structure du même type
donc c'est quelque chose qui
véritablement vient des gîtes le peuple
a construit ces structures là étaient un
peuple est venue d'égypte ça c'est la
première conclusion à laquelle en arrive
et il ya aussi des problèmes et natation
la natation c'est grosso modo la période
de l'exode conclusion nous avons à
l'épreuve les premières preuves
indiscutables
de la réalité historique des récits de
l'exode de la conquête ainsi qu'ils
étaient mis en doute aujourd'hui parce
qu'ils ne croyaient pas dans
l'inspiration biblique essayer au
contraire de la contredire et donc cette
idée de fouler aux pieds la retrouver
aussi dans deux autres textes
lorsque l'as bram à rio le pays d' harry
va donc à s'assécher m et là il
construit un hôtel et construit un hôtel
c'est aussi en quelque sorte prendre
possession spirituellement du pays s'est
consacré le pays odieux que l'on rêvait
et le pays sur lequel on construit un
hôtel et un pays dont le
dieu ne saurait être le suzerain essais
des raisons pour lesquelles par exemple
au carmel aussi la région qui est
contestée entre entre israël et il est
bien est un endroit où il ya un hôtel
les hôtels étaient situés à des endroits
de frontières quand je revois mme de
prend s'empare du royaume du nord il
construit deux hôtels un au sud du pays
à bethel à la frontière sud et au nord à
dan à la frontière nord et quand on a
traversé une frontière à cette époque là
il avait pas des postes frontières comme
aujourd'hui avec des postes de douane et
tout ce qui s'ensuit mais ont rencontré
un hôtel compte rencontrer un hôtel
consacrée à un dieu particuliers aussi
tiens ça y est je suis dans le pays de
ce dieu là donc c'est par exemple c'est
un brave c'est que moche
mal comme si c'est un an moan et caetera
et caetera et bien entendu l'éternel
nous il s'agit du dieu d'israël ça c'est
la première manière de consacrer un pays
au seigneur
la deuxième manière c'est ce que j'ai
dit abraham maintenant que tu a adressé
ses hôtels tu as donc fut conquis
spirituellement le pays en mon nom est
maintenant parcouru à pied dans toute sa
longueur dans toute sa largeur et
parcourir le pays ap c'est aussi en
prendre possession spirituellement
vous retrouver ça aussi dans la deuxième
texte où dieu parle à josué et il lui
dit tout lieu que foudre à la peur de
vos pieds je vous le donne
et voilà donc c'est cette idéologie qui
rapportée ici par ses cinq succès quatre
sanctuaires en forme du pied
en plus des pièges et une fois demandé
adham tartane mais si ça
c'est ta théorie est vrai que c'est un
lieu de culte originaux sont à son nez
en forme de pied on aura trouvé un silo
et un jérusalem et il a une réponse
intéressante et mad et shiloh étaient
détruits puisque ces endroits qui
étaient habités il y avait là bas une
ville qui était construit qui détruit et
reconstruit tu ne restes pas de
souvenirs ici ces raisons qui restaient
comme elle était donc on voit encore les
traces h ils envoient pas une jérusalem
3 une photo aérienne assistée de vie des
français d'autres photos aériennes geste
et david et on revoit sur ce qui est
nouveau c'est que ça reste vrai que
sakho à cette théorie que ça commence à
jéricho ça passe à sichem ça continue à
shilo sichem qui n'ont plus l'hôtel de
l'alliance à l'entrée en israël shiloh
qui va être en 369 francs la capitale
politique et religieux d'israël et le
tabernacle jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive à
l'époque de la royauté et après david
construit jérusalem et on retrouve ces
pièces donc sur son épreuve trajet
depuis jéricho l entrée
intéressant ailleurs aussi de noter
comme je faisais des arts tels que
l'expression pour un pèlerinage les
trois grands pèlerinages qui doivent
avant lieu pour tous juifs c'est pâques
pentecôte et souccot et bien s'appelle
alliant les réelles ça veut dire
littéralement montée vers le pied
personne n'avait compris cette
expression là est tout le monde
traduisent un pèlerinage à pied c'était
la tradition qu'on retrouve dans toutes
les bibles du monde entier et c'est à
dammartin qui propose une autre une
autre traduction d un pèlerinage vers le
pied c'est à dire monter versent des
structures de ce type là dont jérusalem
qui effectivement avait la forme d'un
pied
le jourdain plus pourquoi dans la bible
on retrouve le jourdain
avec les miracles délirer devise est on
voit le jour d'un camp le propre et elle
traverse le jourdain sur son manteau et
de l'autre côté et emmenés par un char
de feu et qu'elle disait votre averses
le jourdain de nouveau sur levante au
déni on trouvera le jourdain dans
l'histoire de naaman chef de l'armée
d'aram qui étaient les preuves et dont
la servante que
juive le dit à sa maîtresse mais lier
qu'il a consulté le prophète en israël
et il sera guéri et cantona man arrive
champs elysées qui plonge toi cette fois
dans le jourdain tu sera guérie prendre
une colère profonde comment ça se fait
et déjà il ya dérive ya bien plus
importantes à damas mais ces servitudes
usuels que c'était avant de plonger en
jourdain il se plonge dans le jourdain
et il est guéri de sa lettre donc le
jourdain est un endroit très important
déjà
depuis toujours et aujourd'hui c'est une
frontière jeudi notre côté cela jordan
et mais oui c'est pas très loin et le
même site que de baptême qui à lui seul
côté si on le trouve aussi du côté juste
en face
jean va
était dans cette région si parce qu'on
était sur la route des pèlerins et
pèlerins qui venaient de la galilée ont
su vivre ce mot de la route que nous
avons fait ce matin mais de l'autre côté
de l'autre côté du jourdain et quand il
arrivait à peu près à cette hauteur là
il traverse l aujourd'hui retraverser le
jourdain pour aller vers jéricho et de
jéricho est monté sur jérusalem grosso
modo la route font nous allons faire ce
soir ce sera la route reçus des pèlerins
et jean baptiste donc qui était le
successeur d lui avait un public tout à
fait approprié à vous demander grand
pèlerinage où il avait donc tout c'est
tout et c'est à sa disposition
quand nous lisons dans le rouge de
marque commencement de l'évangile de
jésus christ fils de dieu sauf que
décrit dans les îles prophète voici je
renvoie devant toi mon message est qu'il
préparera ton chemin c'est la voix de
celui qui crie dans le désert préparer
le chemin du seigneur à planus et ses
sentiers jean paru baptisant dans le
désert et prêchant le baptême de la
repentance pour le pardon des péchés
tout le peuple de judée et tous les
habitants de jérusalem se rendaient
auprès de lui et qu'on fait sans leurs
péchés il serait baptisé par l'ue dans
les eaux du jourdain j'en avais avec
tant de poils de chameau le ceinture de
cuir autour des reins il se nourrissait
de sauterelles et demi un sauvage et
prêché en dix ans vient celui après moi
celui que les plus puissants que moi je
suis pas digne de dédier on ne me
descend l'endroit de ces soulever à
nouveau et baptisé dans l'eau vers il
baptisera dont le saint-esprit
en ce temps là jésus vint de nazareth en
galilée il fut baptisé par jean dans le
jourdain au moment où il sortait de
l'eau le il vu le sien s'ouvrir et
l'esprit décembre celui comme une
colombe et une vraie fille d'entendre
des cieux ces paroles tu es mon fils
bien aimé en toi j'ai mis toute mon
affection
aussitôt l'esprit pousse à jésus dans le
décès il passe à 15 jours tenté par
satan il était avec les bêtes sauvages
et des anges de servais
on monte encore la montagne sur laquelle
jésus a été emmenée par satan qui lui a
montré tous les royaumes de la terre ou
mandat tentation donc dans les déserts
que juste ici à côté de jéricho
sur le site de shiloh qui a été la
capitale d'israël pendant toute la
période des juges jusqu'à l'époque de
samuel et où par conséquent large
alliance s'est trouvée installé avec le
tabernacle tabernacle qui a subi une
certaine transformation puisque il a été
construit en moitié en dur et moitié
avec des tentures ont pesé concerne en
tout cas le la partie supérieure de
l'édifice il ya eu plusieurs événements
qui se sont produits ici et toute
l'histoire de shilo dans la bible et dié
avec l'histoire du prophète samuel et de
du vieux prêtre et lee qui officié ici
hannachi d'eau et là il avait ses deux
fils of neptune rask était dévoré à me
dit la bible et c'est là que hannah donc
la mère du professionnel est venue prier
pour avoir un fils alors qu'elle était
stérile et le saisir dice aussi pour
remercier dieu de lui avoir donné ce
fils panah l'a consacré au seigneur il
est devenu le grand professionnel que
l'on connaît ou travers de la bimbo
travers de la parole de dieu c'est ici à
partir de 1967 que le peuple d'israël
est revenu dans cette région qui était
en territoire jordanien jusqu alors d
habitants juifs sont revenus pour donner
vie aux yeux si de shiloh qui était
totalement abandonné évidemment depuis
l'époque biblique et on a maintenant un
vidage du club d'importance qui se
trouve ici et en même temps qu'eux
village moderne il y à des fouilles
archéologiques toutes les entreprises
qui ont permis de redécouvrir la ville
de l'époque biblique de l'époque du
prophète samuel et du profit et du
prêtre élus et notamment
insultes qui correspond en tout point à
ce que la bulle nous décrit du
sanctuaire parce que pour pouvoir
accéder ici il faut passer à une seule
route possible que la route sud or il
nous est dit que lors de la prise de
l'arche de l'alliance dans la fameuse
bataille déveiner their qu'ait lieu un
peu plus bas dans la vallée
il y attendaient avec angoisse le
résultat de la bataille à côté du
sanctuaire et il a d'abord entendu une
rumeur et ensuite il a eut appris que la
défaite avait été consommée et dans les
maures d'ailleurs quand il a appris
notamment que l'arche de l'alliance
avaient été prises
donc il fallait que cette arche soit
situé plutôt le tabernacle soient
situées dans au nom de du site et de
fait on a retrouvé au nord du site à
l'emplacement qui est exactement les
dimensions du tabernacle et qui a la
forme du tabernacle on n'a pas encore
retrouvé le tavana que lui-même mais
les actionnaires sont sur la piste de
cet de cet emplacement bien sûr les les
fouilles ne sont pas prioritaires dans
le programme des fouilles cette
entreprise par les différentes
organisations qui s'occupent fouillé
deux pays d'israël sait bien que c'est
assez lent comme comme travail mais on a
bon espoir de pouvoir retrouver un jour
les restes du tabernacle mais en tout
cas tout qu'on a retrouvé sa shiloh pour
leur confirme en tous points ce que la
bible nous enseigne
que jésus a rassemblé attribué à tirer
au sort les territoires où chacun et
s'installe et donc il y avait deux urnes
une ak tribune avec les territoires et
c'est ici qu'elle était faite la
répartition il y avait la tribu de juda
avait déjà pris sa part et la tribu de
manassé mais les autres viennent à
shiloh et h et l'eau après la conquête
genève à désirer pas distribuer les
territoires et c'est pour ça qu'on a
cette carte juste en deux manches le
savait mais pour le rappeler il ya donc
deux tribus ennemies qui sont installés
à l'est du jourdain
ce qui est aujourd'hui la jordanie et le
plateau du golan encore eu six ans parti
en syrie
et la tribu de manassé est bien une
partie du côté ouest une partie du côté
est sas la même tribu qui se trouvent
des deux côtés on se regarde la carte on
voit que manas ephraim sur les fils de
joseph ils ont beau morceau et c'est le
centre du pays et quand on reçoit comme
ça un beau morceau au centre du pays ont
bâché le chez le chef le leader jésus
est construit qu'est ce qu'on lui dit on
est une grande tribu pour être ramené à
un territoire aussi petit le syndrome de
l'enfant gâté mais en fait c'est cette
attaque il s'agit le territoire qui
s'accuse qu'il reçoive la montagne
d'ephraïm on est ici actuellement la
bible c'est une forêt vierge
vous avez vu les collines nus qu'on a
vue actuellement ya rien n'y a pas
d'arbres à l'époque où les tribus serait
la rive c'est une forêt très dense et
alors viennent ces tribus en disant je
en un grande tribu nous a donné un grand
territoire mais a pas ou s'installer
dans les vallées il ya la vallée de
shrek c'est la vallée de sichem la
vallée de l'aude dothan dans la vallée
et des cannes à nez avec des chars de
faire non pas ce coup dur avec eux ne
trouvent pas s'installer dans la vallée
de saas dans la montagne et la forêt
vierge où est ce qu'on va et je suis
leur réponds c'est qu'une grande tribu
et culture a beaucoup de force tu
commences à travailler tu vas tu vas
déforester le terrain et il est installé
et on a tellement bien des forestiers
qui reste plus rien
non il ya encore il ya encore des arbres
à l'époque mais avec le temps à l'époque
turque surtout l'époque arabes et turcs
en a ils ont détruit le peu qui reste
est pourquoi je raconte ça parce que les
archéologues arrive
est ce qu'un archéologue préfère c'est
ça
partout on trouve ça ne ment pas les
petits cailloux du caillou sais pas mais
des morceaux de poteries des fragments
de poterie il ya toujours partout ces
traces de l'implantation humaine et
pourquoi c'est important parce qu une
poterie ça peut dater il ya un style
d'abord quels composants rentrer la
couleur de la poterie les dessins là et
industrie donc d'après la forme après
les dessins d'après la décoration on
peut dater une poterie et donc savoir
qu'ils étaient ici à quelle époque or en
israël on retrouve des poteries de
l'époque turque ottomane on retrouve des
poteries de l'époque la croisade
l'époque romaine de l'époque jacques
debuck perse l'époque biblique l'époque
canonné nabab ram l'époque encore doute
de toutes les époques dans cette région
là ya pas de poterie cananéenne la
poterie commence à l'époque juive et
après l'époque israélites des tribus
serait elle donc ça nous corroborent ce
que dit la bible que avant que les
tribus stress s'installe personne
n'était dans cette région dès qu'on sort
de la région de la montagne on a des
poteries
en quantité de l'époque d'abraham dé
connaître dans la montagne plus aucune
poteries de l'époque d'abraham les
poteries commence à l'époque je faisais
ça nous confirme ce que dit la bible que
les tribus l'arrivée dire pas
s'installer ici c'est la forêt vierge et
qu'il faut des tribus les tribus demain
c est frais qui ont commencé à couper la
forêt et comment ces assassins
bienvenue à bethel derrière nous
retrouvons villages arabes s'appelle
beats in ses classiques des noms anciens
que les haines et le health
intervertissent donc beats in peut être
bethel de la bible le lieu correspond
donc à 1167 un archéologue israélien
zeev il n'a y va au village de boot inn
et demande aux villageois et ce qu'ils
ont un lieu ancien lieu
une tradition dans des lieux saints dans
la région et on amène le récit est ce
qu'on trouve ici c'est un macadam
macadam c'est un lieu de pèlerinage
musulman est juste à côté on trouve une
chapelle de l'acropole croisade
nouveau ce que je veux ce que ce que
j'ai dit à l'heure de la tradition reste
si on trouve si on trouve une mosquée
sur une chapelle un pour moi je vous
cherchez ce qu'avec juifs à l'origine à
cet endroit là pourquoi les musulmans et
les chrétiens sur les critères pour les
chrétiens au sud et musulmans sont venus
mettre une chapelle dans cet endroit là
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est on est à
bethel donc ce qu'on cherche c'est
l'endroit du songe de jacob et il ya une
tradition qui veut dire que ce serait le
droit du soja club il faut chercher
parler c'est là la pierre ou jacob pose
la tête je rappelle l'histoire jacob
poursuivi par son frère esaü qui veut sa
peau et il doit s'enfuir isaac dit à
jacob va chez mon beau frère chez la
banque et va là bas chercher une épouse
et jacob kit trêve rhône et va vers le
nord et il dépasse jérusalem et à
l'endroit qui s'appelle bethel la nuit
se couchent brutalement il met la tête
sur une pierre et il fait un rêve dans
ce rêve y voit une échelle avec des
anges qui montent et qui descendent et
il se réveille le matin
ah je suis à la maison dieu sans le
savoir beth l on aimerait me direz
maison de dieu
et dans ce rêve dieu le premier qui sera
avec lui qu'il l'accompagnerait et qui
le ramènerait sains et saufs au pays
la tradition juive est très sensible au
fait que dans le dans l'histoire de son
j'ai remarqué que sur les chaînes et des
anges qui montent et qui descendent ces
créatures viennent du ciel elle aurait
d'abord descendre est ensuite remonté et
déjà rachiq est un commentateur moyen
âge des mésanges monter descendre c'est
les anges qui accompagne et jacob en
israël n'ont pas le droit de partir en
dehors du pays d'israël donc ils
repartent et les anges qui vont
accompagner en dehors du pays d'israël
en seconde qualité c'est eux qui vont
l'accompagner donc il ya un changement
de garde je rappelle que quand il va
revenir il va se mesurer avec un un
homme avec un ange obaldia boc il va
voir là bas deux camps manila près leur
un endroit marc ameil les deux camps il
retrouve de pression ces deux camps
d'ange qui ceux qui se prennent la
relève les anges de d'explora remonte et
s'échange israël qui descendent pour
l'accompagner ça c'est une première la
tradition qui voient ça ici je l'appelle
une chose d un arbre derrière nous qui
est un chêne c'est un des plus vieux
chêne d'israël malheureusement il se
porte pas très bien on essaie de le
soutenir pour éviter qu'ils ne
s'écroulent et quand jacob revient il a
d'abord été à six chaînes où il a acheté
un champ et il continue sa route vers le
sud pour rentrer à la maison et quand
ils arrivent à bethel la nourrice de
rebecca qui l'accompagnait décède il est
enterré sous un chêne à bethel nouveau
ce chêne ici c'est un chêne apparemment
il ya trois mille ans mais sa chaîne qui
nous rappelle ce paysage des chaînes
gérer des camps le tribut serait la rive
dans la région on voit ici une forêt
très dense et
très peu de villages et on voit
un chêne dont qui rappelle un petit peu
ces chaînes qui avait à l'époque
suite de l'histoire c'est mille ans plus
tard quand tu auras le schisme donc
david a unifié les tribus d'israël son
fils salomon a construit le temple et
après une génération
dieu dit qu il va séparer il va couper
la route et de david il va lui laisser
une deux tribus parce qu'ils avaient
promis qu'ils seraient roi jamais mais
des tribus vont être donnés à 1
un autre roi et jéroboam tribu de
descendants de joseph lui va prendre dix
tribus et va faire une nouvelle capitale
sichem et laurie va se rendre compte
qu'il a un problème est son problème
c'est que d'après la lara ne peut
s'asseoir dans le temple à jérusalem
quand on voit là nestea de david
hauquier qu'est ce qui va se passer
maintenant mes sujets vont aller
pèlerinage aux années puisqu'on est juif
on est on à deux états on est en guerre
l'un contre l'autre mais il faut passera
on sert le même dieu d'israël et donc le
pèlerinage se fait jérusalem mes sujets
vont à jérusalem ils vont voir dans le
parvis du temple de roi le roi de juda
et le roi de sichem un qui est assis et
l'autre qui est debout qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont comprendre et un roi qui est
légitime et l'autre qui n'est pas nous
qui comprendront que c'est l'orage
légitime c'est roboam fils david ils
reviendront à un robin et me lâcheront
donc il faut plus que les gens aillent
pèlerinage aux halles m et pour éviter
de plus d'utiliser les prix des choses
là m il va construire deux deux lieux
saints aux confins de son de son royaume
un au sud bethel c'est la frontière sud
j'ai dit à catalca sichem à 40 km au
nord
ici sa frontière sud un hôtel à bethel à
frontière nord à dan au pied du mont
hermon un deuxième hôtel et le pays sein
de jeu robin mais entre ces deux hôtels
il ya encore un petit problème j'ai
expliqué de chaleur que les traders de
change et des dates de pèlerinage des
dates de fait ok mais j'ai au bois mais
c'est aussi ça non seulement à changer
le lieu va changer la date et il va
décaler le camp d'un mois et les fêtes
de d'israël sont décalées d'un mois par
rapport au fait de jérusalem donc c'est
même plus les mêmes
le même date ça va être réunifiée à
l'époque où le royaume du nord lors des
tribus est détruit par le roi d'assyrie
est alors le roi ezéchias roi de juda va
dire aux
survivants de la catastrophe noah une
non vous revenez revenez à revenait à
hamoir revenu à jérusalem il va décaler
la fête je laime d'un mois il va
s'incrire les excellent de l'habitude
ces gens du nord mais voilà c'est la
bonne date venait à jaws façon notre
sanctuaire et détruit venait jérusalem
est ralliez vous à tous le reste du
peuple alors ce qu'on a retrouvé ici on
a retrouvé deux choses d'abord on a
retrouvé un cours avec des pierres
construite qui datait de l'époque et de
dimensions de nouveaux dimension du
tabernacle la taille de la cour de
nouveau c'est ça correspond pour être le
l'enceinte pas là à ce qu'on a vu à
shilo c'était 25 mètres de large sur la
cour du tabernacle là c'est l'argent du
bâtiment 15 m une chose qui dérange la
direction n'est pas bonne
puisque je vous dis que la direction du
tabernacle les actions du temple était
était est ouest au large de soleil ça
c'est le sud je suis en face au sud
l'ouest et là ce bâtiment il est à mi
chemin entre le sud et le sud ouest
alors que josette au sud donc s'ils
devraient être orientés vers l'ouest
c'est à dire vers là dans cette
direction alors de nouveau ce que
pensent les archéologues si on regarde
la direction et les orienter et
l'orienté vers l'endroit du songe de
jacob
donc est ce qu aurait une volonté de
dire il ya déjà un lieu saint aussi
qu'elle songe de jacob il ya une
tradition de lieux saints sont jacob et
donc 7,16 lieux saints étaient tournées
n'ont pas est-ouest mais vers le lieu 5
existait déjà qu est l endroit du change
de jacob tout ça je ne sais pas
quand tu auras passé le jourdain pour
entrer dans le fait que l'éternel ton
dieu te donne tu dressera de grandes
claire et plus endura de chaud tu
écriras toutes les paroles de cette loi
parce que tu n'auras audio rapaces et le
jourdain pour entrer dans le pays que
j'étais adel ton dieu te donne un pays
où coulent le lait et le miel comme le
theule a dit l'éternel le dieu de tes
pères lorsque vous aurez passé le
jourdain vous dresserez déplaire à
propos desquels je vous donne
aujourd'hui des ordres sur le mans et
val tuant durera de show là tu veux sur
un auteur et éternel ton dieu sera un
hôtel de pierre tu ne travaillera pas
avec le faire c'est avec des prêts bruts
que tu construiras l'hôtel dieu
l'éternel ton dieu tu écriras d
holocauste à l'éternel ton dieu tu
aurais a aussi des sacrifices de
communion tu ne mangeras très jeunes
futurs réjouira là devant l'éternel ton
dieu tu iras tu sur ces pluies à toutes
les paroles de cette loi en les gravant
bien nettement
briser les prêtres et les vis tu diras
l'ensemble d'israël soit avant soit
attentifs aujourd'hui sur hull pas de
l'éternel parmi les découvertes et plus
extraordinaires de ces dernières années
sur le plan de l'archéologie entre
israël et la découverte de cet hôtel
quand il est question dans la lecture
que nous avons fait sur le mans et vale
cette découverte est le fruit des
recherches du professeur
adam zertal décédé récemment qui a été
un des produits et faiseurs de toute la
région de la samarie et déjà il ya
nombre d'années qu'il a découvert une
structure pas loin du sommet du mont et
vale qui est en tout point semblable à
un hôtel et c'était un hôtel qui
manifestement est un outil street il n'y
avait pas de statut il n'y avait pas de
représentation d'une divinité quel que
soit
il y avait par contre
des ossements d'animaux
qu'ils étaient tous des animaux cacher
il y avait par exemple absolument aucun
ossement de porc et le professeur attal
est arrivé à la conclusion qu'il
s'agissait bel et bien de l'aisne
l'hôtel a été construit par josué cet
hôtel était conforme c'est à nous tel
que décrit dans le livre de l'exode
c'est à dire telle ou telle
rectangulaire avec des quatre points ce
qu'on appelle des cornes c'est à dire
des structures qui sortait de l'hôtel on
y accéder par une rampe et non pas par
des marches et ça c'est aussi une des
prescriptions qui est donné aux
israélites pour la construction d'un
hôtel à internet parce qu'il est écrit
tu ne montera pas à l'hôtel par des
marches de peur que la nudité de soit
découverte et puis il y avait tout
autour de l'hôtel proprement dit son
appel a en hébreu a sauvé c'est à dire
une sorte de rampe sur laquelle se
tenait les
adorateurs continue pendant que les
prêtres au frais les sacrifices et cet
hôtel
a été datés avec précision de l'époque
de la conquête par josué est notamment
par le fait que l'on ait retrouvé de
scarabées portant l'effigié de pharaon
ramsès deux hommes cessent de qui serait
le pharaon de l'exode et par conséquent
on a un hôtel lucic et à thé de
l'époque de la conquête qui est
semblable à ce qui est décrit dans le
livre de l'a21 livre du deutéronome et
dans le livre de josué où nous et
rapport rapporté comment josué est à
exécuter l'ordre avait été donné par
moïse avant l'entrée dans la terre
promise et de ce fait comme disait le
professeur d'art talent si je rencontre
un animal qui marche comme un canard qui
nagent comme un canard qu'un bug
semblable à un canard je conclus que
c'est un canard donc ici nous avons un
hôtel que semblable à tout ce qui est
écrit dans la bible nous avons des
raisons de penser que c'est bel et bien
l'hôtel de josué qui a été construit sur
le mans et vale
c'est une région assez isolé au sud du
pays où les gens veulent vivre à l'écart
des romains mais on voit une vie juive
qui s'il est juif très très vivante
puisque on voit la taille de la
synagogue c'est un gag de deux familles
qui habitent ici c'est une communauté
vibrante et jeudi elle commence son 4ème
5ème siècle quelques détails de la
cheville sont très spéciaux les skyblogs
ont tourné vers jérusalem mais l'entrée
par l'est je vais être d'autres
synagogue c'est une grande discussion
par ou en train synagogue c'est vrai
qu'au temple aux rentrées par l'ess vu
le jour on allait vers l'ouest le saint
des saints qu est l ouest premières
choses spécifiques à cette synagogue
deuxième chose si vous avez la porte
parce que vous n'êtes pas si vous avez
eu la grosse pierre reid à pierre
roulante l'aquifère morts on a parlé de
ses pieds pour fermer des tombes pour
empêcher des animaux sauvages de venir
dévorer les les corps enterrés mais
pourquoi une pierre de cette taille là
il faut donc comprendre que cette
synagogue a aussi une fonction défensive
une synagogue d'après la tradition
d'être qu'on doit être construit se
vendra le plus haut du village on
effectivement dominici le village qui en
dessous de nous donc c'est l'endroit le
plus au seul endroit stratégique man le
mieux pour la défense donc en cas d'
attaque la sérénade sert aussi de
forteresse pour se cacher et donc et
cette grosse pierre roulante qui promet
de fermer la porte et d'empêcher un
assaillant de rentrée c'est plus une
pierre roulante ça beaucoup plus
défensif qu'une porte une porte
s'enfonce une pierre roulante il faut la
faire rouler il subit mais deux cailloux
en dessous elle ne roule plus et on
pourrait la pousser à nouveau le
vouvoyer le poids qu'elle qu'elle pèse
et ça ne roule plus la porte et la porte
est bien fermée derrière indices sur
votre droite ya ce tunnel qui permet en
cas d' attaque aux gens qui sont dehors
de la ville de venir se replier sur la
synagogue ça peut bien sûr aussi si la
synagogue est sur le point d'être d'être
prise aux gens qui sont à l'intérieur de
partir et de ressortir d'un campagne en
dehors du champ de bataille donc deux
côtés ça permet de rentrer
rendez vous de sortir sans être vu donc
on comprend que c'est aux synagogues qui
a aussi un but défensif je rappelle ce
que j'ai à dire on est aux confins du
pays alimi du désert sur la frontière
après nous commence l'idu mais à
l'époque romaine c'est un autre pays des
élus mais un et donc il faut se protéger
est donc cette synagogue est à la fois
un lieu de prière un lieu de culte mais
c'est aussi une forteresse qui protège
le village